Hallo und herzlich willkommen. Frohes Neues 2025 und auch zum Chaos Radio 297.
Oh mein Gott, die 300 ist bald voll, was machen wir da?
Wahrscheinlich auch weiterhin digitale Dinge erklären, die für interessierte
Ahnungslose und den Rest der Welt von Interesse sind oder sein sollten manchmal.
Und dieses Mal machen wir was brandaktuelles, weil uns ist ja aus diversen Gründen,
hat uns ja eine Bundestagswahl ereilt. und wie es die Tradition will,
geht es da mal mehr und mal weniger auch um Digitalpolitik.
Und ich will jetzt nicht sagen, dass wir die Digital-Wahl-O-Mat wären,
aber vielleicht wisst ihr am Ende dieser Sendung ein bisschen besser,
was die verschiedenen Parteien davon, was die verschiedenen Parteien versprechen,
muss man ja tatsächlich sagen.
Ob das dann auch so kommen wird, ist ja mal eine andere Sache,
aber vielleicht können wir auch das kurz beleuchten.
Also das wollen wir heute eben machen. Mit dabei ist wie immer Konstanze Kurz,
die mich jetzt schon wieder anguckt, als hätte ich Jan Bart gefressen. Hallo und guten Tag.
Hallo Markus.
Konz ist Sprecherin, eine der SprecherInnen des CCC und arbeitet bei Netzpolitik.org
und ist mittlerweile auch eine der treibenden inhaltlichen Kräfte.
Hallo, ich sag mich eben schon, willst du nochmal? Was man mal nicht unerwähnt lassen sollte.
Außerdem Aline Blankertz, wo es mit der Forschung so ein bisschen schwierig
ist, weil wenn man jetzt sagt, Digitalexpertin, das kann ja alles bedeuten und
hat also gerade, wenn man auch größere institutionalisierte Medien anguckt,
manchmal einen eher zweifelhaften Geruch, diese Bezeichnung.
Deswegen könnte man vielleicht sagen, also Digitalfachfrau aus dem politisch
und aktivistischen Umfeld, in dem im weiteren Sinne auch der Chaos Computer
Club zu finden sein könnte. Ist das richtig?
Das klingt wunderbar.
Und dann noch ein Gast, der für mich persönlich eine sehr große Überraschung war.
Vielleicht wird klar, warum, wenn ich sage, ich begrüße jetzt die Geschäftsführung
von diversen Internet- und Telekommunikationsunternehmen in Europa,
der Industrievertretung in Berlin und Brüssel macht und Vorstand Infrastruktur
und Netze bei ECO, dem Verband der Internetwirtschaft ist. Hallo und herzlich
willkommen, Glaus Landefeld.
Ja, hallo. Jetzt fühle ich mich so ein bisschen, ich weiß nicht.
Ja, ich muss da was hinzufügen.
Richtig, aber.
Also man muss es kurz erklären, man muss es aber auch sagen.
Du bist sozusagen beim Verband der Internetwirtschaft, der, also wenn ich es
richtig verstanden habe, schon der deutsche Verband ist, aber weltweit Mitglieder
auch hat, aber der Verband für Deutschland ist.
Und wenn man das so aus dem ersten Blickwinkel sieht, fragt man sich vielleicht
schon so, Moment mal, Chaos Computer Club, da sitzen die Leute,
die wollen ein offenes, freies Netz, in dem jeder alles machen kann.
Und Internetwirtschaft verbindet man vielleicht schon ein bisschen mit,
wir wollen vor allen Dingen Profit damit machen.
Wie passt das zusammen? Warum bist du heute hier? Und welche Überschneidungspunkte
gibt es vielleicht zwischen Hackerarbeit und Eco-Internet-Wirtschaftsarbeit?
Ich meine, okay, Ziel von Unternehmen ist natürlich Geld zu verdienen. Das ist völlig klar.
Und dabei ist erstmal völlig egal, ob man wirklich Infrastruktur aufbaut,
ob man Cloud-Services betreibt, ob man Social Media betreibt.
Also in der Regel wollen die Unternehmen nur mit Geld verdienen.
Aber wir haben natürlich sehr viele Berührungspunkte mit dem CCC,
schon seit Ewigkeiten eigentlich.
Wir haben in sehr vielen digitalpolitischen Themen zusammengearbeitet,
haben egal vom Hacker-Paragraf über Vorratsdatenspeicherung,
Netzneutralität und so weiter, eigentlich immer auf derselben Seite gestanden
und haben das auch in Expertenanhörungen im Bundestag, in Stellungnahmen, sonst was.
Es gibt auch unglaublich viele offene Briefe, die wir gemeinschaftlich unterzeichnet haben.
Von daher ist es vielleicht nicht ganz so entfernt, wie man sich das denkt.
Ja, okay. So und auch du hast ja sozusagen Wahlprogramme durchgelesen.
Das haben sich ja alle drei heute hier und ich bin ganz froh,
dass ich das sozusagen nicht machen musste und ihr müsst das auch nicht machen,
weil sozusagen das haben die ExpertInnen für euch getan. Was ich gerne machen
würde, sind drei Sachen.
Also eine kleine Ausführung und ein kleiner Abschluss ist eine Sache.
Das andere ist, es gibt ja so die großen Digitalthemen, wo man sich immer fragt,
was wird denn jetzt damit?
Das eine ist ganz klassisch, wann hat endlich jeder Haushalt Glasfaser?
Das andere ist, welche Partei ist für oder gegen die Vorratsdatenspeicherung?
Es gibt halt immer so ein paar Themen, die wichtig sind, die würde ich einmal
abfragen wollen und dann könnt ihr uns vielleicht erzählen, wie stehen denn
die einzelnen Parteien dazu.
Und dann, weil das ja nicht alles ist, gehen wir vielleicht nochmal die Parteien
durch und fragen sozusagen, an deren Programm ist da irgendwas aufgefallen,
gibt es da was Besonderes oder was mich auch immer interessieren würde ist,
in die Programmen klingt das mega gut und
Aber die Vergangenheit hat gezeigt, die Partei lügt. Was mir spontan einfällt,
ist die Haltung der SPD zur Vorratssatzspeicherung.
Ich weiß jetzt auch nicht, wie ich dazu komme, aber vielleicht gibt es ja so
eine Punkte wieder, dann können wir die auch da beleuchten. Genau.
Ich würde vielleicht noch was hinzufügen wollen, damit man irgendwie so ein
bisschen versteht, wie wir darauf kamen, warum wir das überhaupt machen wollten.
So diese Chaos-Radio zur Wahl, jetzt nicht nur wegen des anstehenden Termins,
sondern ein bisschen auch die Überlegung, irgendwie findet in der Debatte wenig Digitalität statt.
Also die politischen Streitthemen sind ziemlich weit weg davon und die Schwerpunkte
der Wahlprogramme, da nicken jetzt schon alle, das hat man auch gemerkt beim Lesen.
Und wir wollten aber trotzdem gerade mal auf diese Aspekte blicken.
Was sagen die da eigentlich zu? Denn im Wahlkampf selber werden die mit hoher
Wahrscheinlichkeit nur am Rande stattfinden.
Das zeichnet sich ja jetzt schon ab. Wir haben ja nur noch sechs Wochen.
Ich weiß nicht, wie lange die Post-Production dauern wird, aber möglicherweise
sind es dann bloß noch vier Wochen oder so.
Ich habe vier Wochen vor der Wahl.
Also ein Anliegen ist auch, dass man überhaupt wieder über diese Aspekte auch
redet. Wir wissen irgendwie, dass Digitalisierung das Herz jedes
Das muss ich jetzt nicht sagen.
Wir kommen noch dazu. Und das geht ja leider auch gerade Hand in Hand,
weil nach den schrecklichen Dingen, die am Jahresende noch passiert wurden,
wurde natürlich erstmal wieder mehr Überwachung gefordert und das dann kombiniert
mit der Bundestagswahl,
wo diese Themen eigentlich gar nicht stattfinden, ist natürlich auch sozusagen
so eine brisante Mischung.
Vielleicht können wir dann ein bisschen zur Aufklärung beitragen.
Ich würde das allgemein gerne nochmal unterstützen. Wenn ich mir Wahlprogramme
aus 2021 oder zur Europawahl noch angucke, Dann ist Digitalisierung ein ganz
wichtiges Thema. Das waren eigene Hauptthemen.
Das waren Themen, die die Parteien insgesamt aufgenommen haben.
Und was wir jetzt haben, ist Digitalisierung ist zwar überall irgendwie so ein bisschen drin.
Es kommt tausendmal vor in den Wahlprogrammen, überall an jeder Ecke.
Aber es hat so ein bisschen, es ist irgendwie unter andere Themen gerutscht.
Das sind immer so Unterpunkte geworden.
Das ist glaube ich ein ganz generelles Ding, das durch alle Wahlprogramme sich durchzieht.
Ich will vielleicht noch eine zweite Vorbemerkung machen.
Und dann ist das Chaos heute auch schon vorbei.
Nein, ich will es deswegen machen, weil wir drei haben uns die angeguckt und du nicht.
Und wer jetzt die nicht gelesen hat, der weiß es schlicht nicht.
Wir haben nicht Wahlprogramme gleicher Güte und Qualität von den großen Parteien,
sondern wir haben mehrere Parteien, die quasi erwartbar relativ viele Prozente
haben werden und locker über die fünf Prozente springen werden,
die fast keine inhaltlichen Programme haben, sondern nur mehr so Faltblätter.
Das heißt, die längsten Programme, die sehr ausdifferenziert sind wie von der
CDU und von der SPD, kann man nicht vergleichen zum Beispiel mit diesem Mini-Zettel
vom BSW oder so. Also die sind qualitativ sehr unterschiedlich.
Die liegen natürlich an dieser krassen, einfach zeitlichen Enge.
Die haben glaube ich offenbar nicht geschafft und selbst die langen Programme,
die man lesen kann, die sind ja eigentlich auch vorläufig.
Ja, das sind alle zu kurz.
Also alle so um den 18. und 17. Dezember rumgeschaffene Kurzprogramme vergleichsweise.
Da hätte man gedacht, warte mal zu.
Ich will es nur erwähnen, weil wir davon ausgehen, dass jetzt nicht alle Leser
sich hinstellen und irgendwie diese PDFs da lesen.
Genau, ich fände aber gut, wenn du es an der Stelle, wenn wir darüber reden,
nochmal ganz explizit sagen konntest.
Und das andere ist sozusagen, es gibt so einen Elefant im Raum,
einen blauen Elefant, der mich in meiner Arbeit als Journalist sozusagen oft so ein bisschen sticht.
Und dass es eine Partei gibt, die zum Teil aus,
wie heißt es immer so schön, juristisch anerkannten, darf man Faschistzusagen
Leuten besteht und die, und da macht meiner Meinung nach, deutscher Journalismus
einen großen Fehler, gleichberechtigt behandelt wird, neben allen anderen Parteien.
Und mein Gefühl für diese Sendung, ich kann natürlich jetzt nicht den Mund verbieten
oder ich cancel, das wäre ja noch schöner, aber mein Gefühl für diese Sendung
ist, ich würde gerne diesen Fehler nicht machen wollen und würde deswegen nichts
zur AfD sagen wollen, weil Faschisten gehören einfach nicht im Bundestag,
egal was die im Digitalprogramm mal schreiben.
Vielleicht können wir am Ende so sagen, kurz sagen wie viel und haben die Strahlkraft
und sowas, aber ich würde die eigentlich aus dieser allgemeinen Diskussion,
die wir heute über das digitale Deutschland führen, ausschließen wollen. Wie steht die dazu?
Ja, ich will die halt nicht. Also der CCC hat seit langem einen Unvereinbarkeitsbeschluss
mit irgendwie so Rechtsextremen.
Ich würde sie im Prinzip, ich habe mir natürlich jetzt das Programm angesehen,
das werden wahrscheinlich die anderen vielleicht auch gemacht haben,
aber sie haben halt für mich auch in Digitalfragen wenig zu sagen.
Insofern würde ich es nicht vermissen.
Geht mir ähnlich. Wir haben schon direkt nach der Wahl, nach der letzten Bundestagswahl
als Verband, einen Beschluss gemacht, dass wir mit denen nicht zusammenarbeiten.
Ist jetzt aber leider kein kleiner blauer Elefant mehr. Und es hat sich im Prinzip
das, was man auch im Bundestag immer gesehen hat, in den ganzen Gremienarbeiten
und so weiter, dass da nichts Konstruktives kam.
Das habe ich auch im Wahlprogramm so gesehen. Und da ist halt außerhalb von
dem, wo man immer das Gefühl hat, in Social Media sind sie präsent und man da
vielleicht irrig zu der Meinung kommen könnte, dass sie Digitalkompetenz haben,
ist halt in allem, was echte digitalpolitische Themen sind.
Ist einfach nichts. Aber da muss ich auch mal spitze mich fragen.
Würde ich jetzt gerne über das AfD-Programm reden wollen, wenn es total geil wäre?
Nee, also es
Wäre halt vielleicht spannend, wenn sie sich da, ich sag mal,
positiv abgrenzen würden, von allem, wo man sagen müsste, das ist extrem schade dann, aber,
naja, es ist halt wie immer, es ist nur destruktiv komplett, sonst nichts.
Also man kann sie für ihre fehlende Digitalkompetenz kritisieren,
aber das ist aus meiner Sicht nicht der wesentliche Punkt, also ich sehe das
eigentlich, oder ich sehe das ganz genauso, dass es
Hilfreich ist nicht über sie zu reden, ihnen keinen Raum zu geben,
eben weil sie insgesamt die Menschenwürde angreifen, menschenfeindlich sind.
Und selbst wenn sie die tollste Digitalpolitik der Welt machen würden,
die Zwecke, die sie damit letztlich verfolgen, sind so problematisch,
dass es da keine Fachpolitik gibt, die das aufwiegen kann.
Wir haben ehrlicherweise überlegt, ob wir jetzt auch noch andere Parteien eigentlich
da rein, also namentlich BSW, die ja gerade so den Migrationsfragen ziemlich nah sind.
Aber da die nicht mal ein richtig vollständiges Programm haben und noch so neu
sind, da ist es noch schwierig,
Die gleich sozusagen… Haben also noch eine Chance, sich zu benehmen, meinst du?
Das wissen wir noch nicht.
Also ich habe es auch aus gewisser Neugier gelesen beim BSW und nicht so richtig
wusste, was kommt da eigentlich, was ist da. insofern, wir empfehlen schon trotzdem
ihr nicht müssen, wenn wir jetzt ja drüber reden inhaltlich, man kann nie mal lesen.
Also für mich jedenfalls, für meine eigene persönliche Meinungsbildung,
jeder von uns muss ja irgendwie das Kreuz machen, wenn er möchte natürlich nur
das Kreuz machen, war das schon sehr hilfreich.
Also ich hab's eigentlich jetzt nicht gut, ich bin radikalisiert worden nach
der Lektüre und ich hatte auch mentale Schäden, aber im Prinzip.
Also ich würde es trotzdem jedem empfehlen, ehrlich mal, klickt da mal hin.
Ich weiß nicht so genau, Anyways, wir reden heute nicht weiter drüber.
So, genau. Dann, wie eigentlich könnte ich, würde ich jetzt gerne sozusagen
die großen Fragen angehen und dann von euch wissen wollen, was gibt es denn da für Versprechen?
Ich glaube, wir sollten heute immer über Versprechen reden. Als viel mehr kann
man es wirklich nicht bezeichnen. Das zeigt die Historia.
Und die eine schöne Frage ist, also das letzte Mal oder das vorletzte Mal war
es, 5G an jeder Milchkanne, der digitale Ausbau, die Infrastruktur in Deutschland.
Also tatsächlich habe ich im näheren Umfeld Menschen, die haben mittlerweile
in ihrem Wochenendhäuschen mehr Glasfaser als in ihrer Großstadtwohnung.
Wo immer noch Kupfer liegt. Vielleicht
könntet ihr ganz kurz auch mal dazu sagen, wo stehen wir gerade?
Oh, das kann Klaus bestimmt gut.
Zufälligerweise haben wir da einen Experten da.
Ja, tatsächlich. Ja, wo stehen wir? Ich meine, eines der großen Probleme hier
ist, dass man da über viel redet, was angeleiert ist, wo Förderung schon vergeben
ist und so weiter, aber ein Ausbau dauert.
Das ist immer das Problem mit physischem Ausbau. Physischer Ausbau dauert einfach.
Zehn verpeilte Jahre in den 2000ern kann man halt einfach nicht so ohne weiteres
aufholen, insbesondere wenn man in Genehmigungen, in sonst was in den eigentlichen
Verlegungen nicht schneller wird.
Das ist halt einfach so. Und es hilft auch nicht unbedingt, wenn man auf dem
Land anfängt, wo man einfach viel Meter legen muss, bevor man Häuser angeschlossen hat.
Würde man in den Städten beginnen, hätte man in den Städten mit dem Glasfaserausbau
begonnen, dann hätten wir einen wesentlich höheren Prozentsatz schon an Glasfaser angeschlossen.
Also das erstmal zu der Frage, wo kommt das Problem eigentlich in Teilen her?
Kannst du ein bisschen international auch vergleichen?
Oh, international sind wir total rückständig, aber tatsächlich.
Also das muss man ganz klar so sagen, wenn man OECD-Zahlen sich anguckt,
da sind wir drittletzter, glaube ich, oder sowas im Moment.
Yippie, ey komm, nicht letzter. Nicht letzter, das stimmt allerdings.
Wer ist dahinter? Und interessant ist insbesondere, es gibt sehr schöne vergleichende
Zahlen darüber, wie schnell in den einzelnen Ländern aufgebaut wird und allen
Beteuerungen des Digitalministeriums zum Trotz betrachten.
War das nicht so besonders massiv?
Also andere Länder haben noch deutlich schneller als wir das aufgebaut.
Von daher hat man, auch wenn die Zahlen absolut viel besser geworden sind,
natürlich relativ im Vergleich zum Ausland nicht wirklich aufgeholt.
Das ist ein ganz entscheidender Punkt, den muss man einfach mal feststellen.
Insbesondere sind natürlich auch selbst in Europa einige Länder einfach schon
fertig. Da ist alles ausgebaut. Da ist man bei ein paar 90 Prozent.
Alles ausgebaut? Meinst du, überall liegt Glasfaser?
Ja, überall ist natürlich so gut wie nie der Fall, aber alles,
was irgendwie relevant ist, was sich wirtschaftlich erschließen lässt mit Glasfaser,
das ist ja ein ganz entscheidender Punkt.
Aber also Detailfrage dazu sagen, das heißt Ausbau gleich Glasfaser,
die Frage mit dem Mobilfunknetz spielt nicht so eine große Rolle?
Ja doch, also ich meine jeder, wenn man 5G-Ausbau betreibt, da muss man auch
Glasfaser in der Fläche haben, sonst kriege ich das nicht hin.
Die Zellgrößen sind ja immer relativ gering, sind einige Kilometer maximal und
das heißt, ich muss in der Fläche Glasfaser haben, um die Türme anschließen
zu können, ansonsten habe ich kein echtes 5G und wir reden ja also immer über
5G-Ausbau, eigentlich nicht über,
4G hat zwar auch sehr hohe Geschwindigkeiten, die man da erreichen kann,
das reicht natürlich für eine Breitbandversorgung auch aus, aber generell wird
immer über 5G-Ausbau gehört.
Also das heißt, das Thema ist natürlich wahrscheinlich unfassbar und unendlich
komplex, aber am Glasfaserausbau kann man sehr gut sehen, wo steht ein Land.
Da sind wir also drittletzter in der OECD.
Was versprechen denn, also was wird uns denn versprochen? Platz eins nach der nächsten?
Ja, Frau Kurz? Der beste Spin aus meiner Sicht ist bei der SPD im Wahlprogramm.
Wir lachen ja schon immer drüber, weil es ja selbstverständlich in allen Wahlprogrammen
immer drin ist und dann auch in den Koalitionsverhandlungen.
Aber die SPD hat einen neuen Spin und ich würde das kurz mal vortragen, sind nur zwei Sätze.
Die SPD schreibt in ihrem SPD-Regierungsprogramm, beim Abbau von Bürokratie
nutzen wir die Chancen der Digitalisierung.
Die Grundlage dafür bildet eine flächendeckende Versorgung des ganzen Landes
mit Glasfaser und Mobilfunk.
Sie verbinden es also seit Neuestem mit dem Abbau von Bürokratie,
denn wenn man die Glasfaser dahin legt, wie ihr wisst,
Baut sich die Bürokratie ab. Ich fand den Spin, der ist neu.
Sie können ja nicht immer exakt selber reinschreiben, das ist ja dann noch peinlicher.
Ich fand den Spin schön. Da kommt die Glasfaser und dann sind wir.
Aber versprechen Sie irgendwas, was den Ausbau angeht?
Flächendeckende Versorgung des ganzen Landes?
Innerhalb der nächsten Legislaturperiode?
Das steht da nicht.
Achso, okay. Also jetzt mal ganz praktisch, das geht gar nicht.
Also es ist faktisch nicht innerhalb der nächsten Legislaturperiode durchzuführen.
Also die fehlenden Strecken, die fehlenden Haushaltschlüsse,
die wir haben, lassen sich nicht innerhalb von vier Jahren schließen.
Punkt. Jeder, der das verspricht, verspricht etwas, was einfach nicht geht.
Es ist unabhängig davon, wie viel Geld wir da draufwerfen.
Das ist einfach wegen der physisch zu leistenden Ausbauarbeit.
Das ist einfach nicht Major Construction Work, sagt man im Englischen so schön.
So viel Bagger haben wir einfach gar nicht und das Personal schon gar nicht, die das legen könnten.
Also von daher wäre das auch unrealistisch. Es ist aber tatsächlich eins der
Digitalthemen, die sich immer noch in allen Wahlprogrammen wiederfindet.
Und die anderen Themen sind nicht mehr unbedingt da, aber dieses Glasfaserausbau
oder Breitbandausbau, das hat sich ja erst in der letzten Legislaturperiode,
nein der vorletzten schon so richtig zum Glasfaserausbau gewandelt.
Vorher war es ja mal Breitbandausbau, jetzt ist es Glasfaserausbau.
Das wollen alle, das schreiben auch alle rein, dass das als Voraussetzung für
die Digitalisierung der Gesellschaft natürlich auch die Digitalisierung von
Verwaltungsleistungen wichtig ist.
Und deswegen kommt es überall vor. So richtig ausgestaltet ist es aber eigentlich
nicht. Man will die Förderprogramme wieder hochfahren in einigen Bereichen.
Aber wie das ansonsten konkret gemacht werden soll, Verwaltungsverfahren sollen
beschleunigt werden, also dass die Genehmigungen schneller gehen,
dass der Ausbau wieder schneller wird, das findet sich eigentlich so ziemlich überall.
Ansonsten neue Ideen findet man dann nirgends.
Also alle versprechen irgendwie Ausbau, aber niemand sagt was Konkretes?
Das ist eigentlich die Fortsetzung von dem, was wir machen.
Wollen wir es mal kurz sagen? Es ist nicht wirklich was Neues da irgendwo drin,
das ist immer die Fortsetzung von dem, was wir schon haben.
Nicht alle erwähnt, also nicht alle erwähnt. Die Kurzprogramme haben wir gar nicht drin.
In den Kurzprogrammen ist es nicht, aber wenn man sich die Zusammenfassung anhanden,
findet man es auch nicht mehr.
Also es ist alles, was Kurzprogramme sind, hat es quasi eigentlich gar nicht
mehr, nur die langen Programme haben es dann aber alle im Prinzip drin.
Aber niemand sozusagen will sie auf eine Zahl festlegen, auf eine Prozentzahl des Ausbruchs oder so.
Ich will auch keiner sich dazu äußern, wie viele Jahre wir noch brauchen.
In der letzten Legislatur hat man mal gesagt, bis 2030, das ist schon von vielen
in Frage gestellt werden, ob das geht oder nicht.
Wir haben jetzt schon 25, sind ja nur fünf Jahre. Stimmt, ja.
Mittlerweile ist es 20, 30.
Das ist quasi noch eine Legislatur. Nein, aber das ist eigentlich illusorisch,
dass man da wirklich fertig wird, weil wir einfach, man muss sagen,
nicht so wirklich gut vorankommen.
Also es wird viel investiert und es hat jetzt insbesondere ja auch,
muss man auch mal sagen, die Telekom sich committet, deutlich mehr auszubauen
und die haben auch dann tatsächlich eine wesentlich höhere Schlagzahl als viele
andere das hatten im Ausbau.
Aber es ist, wie gesagt, es ist einfach praktisch nicht mehr durchführbar.
Wir sind einfach zu spät. Wir sind bestimmt fünf Jahre zu spät hinten dran in
der Kurve, auch im europäischen Vergleich.
Aber dass es keine konkreten Zahlen gibt, ist ja etwas, was in allen Themen
eigentlich typisch ist in diesem Wahlprogramm.
Also dass man sich keine Ziele steckt, bei denen man hinterher sagen kann,
wie viel davon hat funktioniert, ist nicht nur beim Glasfaser-Ausbau so.
Also das muss ich mal sagen, es macht ja nicht der Staat, es machen ja Privatunternehmen
an dieser Stelle, die staatlich inzentiviert werden, es zu machen,
aber der Staat hat ja noch nicht mal bei den Sachen, die er selber machen könnte,
also Verwaltungsdigitalisierung und sonst was funktioniert, also ist vielleicht doch besser so.
Aber der Staat, der könnte ja schon sozusagen Ziele ausgeben oder anstreben.
Das ist ja genau der Punkt. Ich meine, positiv könnte man sie jetzt aufschreiben,
niemand verspricht Dinge, die er nicht halten kann.
Ich habe noch sozusagen, weil das fast so in den Bereich Hardware reingeht oder
Infrastrukturbereitstellung und wir gerade, wir nehmen auf am 8.
Januar und die Verbraucherzentrale hat gerade die Telekom gemahnt,
dass die das Peering nicht ordentlich machen. Und ich erkläre es jetzt nur ganz,
ganz einfach sozusagen.
Die Telekom leitet nicht, so ist der Vorwurf, jeden Datenstrom gleich durch,
sondern bei großen Anbietern sagen sie, nee, wenn ihr wollt,
dass das sozusagen so schnell geht, wie wir können, müsst ihr nochmal extra
was bezahlen. Das ist...
Nicht die Idee. Die Idee ist, man kauft einen Internetanschluss und der sozusagen macht da,
Also.
Oh, jetzt will er uns triggern, oder? Jetzt will er uns triggern, ich weiß nicht.
Netzneutralität ist eine eigene Verantwortung.
Ja, wir können doch nicht ernsthaft.
Doch, doch, doch, kann man schon.
Nämlich die Frage ist, in welchem Parteiprogramm spielt das eine Rolle?
Die Netzneutralität, also generell Peering-Fragen.
Ich hab's in keinem gesehen.
Nee, auch in null. Weder CDU, SPD, wo ja die längsten sind. Aline,
hast du irgendwie, kannst du, sonst würden wir sagen, nirgendwo.
Ich frage mich gerade, ob ich es bei der FDP gesehen habe.
Aber ich bin nicht ganz sicher, ob ich es bei der FDP vielleicht gesehen habe.
Oh, ich habe die ausgelassen, weil ich davon ausgehe, dass, oh, schön.
Lieber blaue Elefanten lesen als
FDP, wow. Ist das schon eine politische Aussage, man weiß es nicht genau.
Ich habe tatsächlich wenig Hoffnung, dass die Liberalen, aber das ist ja heute
nicht unser Thema. Ich glaube nicht, dass sie überstehen.
Ansonsten schade, weil die hatten tatsächlich die ganzen Digitalthemen noch drin.
Richtig, ja richtig.
Aber die BK ist vom letzten Mal, oder?
Ja, stimmt.
Okay, können wir nachher noch genau beschreiben. Ja, können wir noch.
Also gut, das Thema ist zu komplex, hat niemand auf dem Schirm,
was interessant ist, weil es natürlich sehr, sehr wichtig ist.
Aber Klaus, wir können gerne noch mal ein Chaos-Reihe zur Netzneutralität machen.
Das ist immer wieder ein total spannendes Thema, weil es jetzt schon anklang
und das ist ja das zweite wichtige oder ein Thema, was immer wieder eine Rolle spielt.
Jetzt könnte man im weitesten Sinne sagen, auch gerade aktuell mit der elektronischen
Patientenakte. Also der digitale Staat.
Jetzt hat Konz gerade schon gesagt, die SPD sagt, aha, Kommunismus ist gleich
Arbeitskraft plus Elektrifizierung.
Ach nein, Entschuldigung, ist
gleich digitaler Staat, ist gleich Glasfaserausbau plus Bürokratieabbau.
Was genau zum digitalen Staat oder der digitalen Bürokratie,
der digitalen Verwaltung, der Offenheit, Transparenz und so weiter und so fort.
Das ist ein riesiger Themenkomplex, den man aber eben unter digitale Zugänglichkeit
des Staates zusammenfassen kann.
Wer verspricht uns da einen zugänglichen Staat, der gleichzeitig auf unsere
Daten achtet und alles so einfach wie möglich macht?
Kann man sagen, alle, oder? Also alle sagen, was von Abbau, von Bürokratie habe ich so entdeckt.
Ich weiß nicht, habt ihr spezielle Sachen entdeckt, die euch aufgefallen sind?
Also ich finde es wichtig, den Punkt nochmal zu machen, den du gerade beim Blasphaser-Ausbau
angesprochen hast. Nämlich, dass das so ein bisschen Magical Thinking ist.
Wir machen Digitalisierung und dann kommt es zu Bürokratieabbau.
Was halt, also sorry, in den letzten Jahren halt, also ich würde nicht sagen,
also vielleicht sogar in die entgegengesetzte Richtung funktioniert hat,
weil man teilweise ja so digitalisiert hat, dass das Dinge noch komplizierter gemacht hat.
Also vernünftig zu digitalisieren, das ist, also habe ich an keiner Stelle sauber
operationalisiert gesehen.
Aber alle blasen in das Horn von, wir wollen Bürokratie abbauen und Dinge einfacher
machen. Es gibt da noch mal so unterschiedliche Nuancen.
Die Union will an vielen Stellen die Hürden dafür abbauen in Form der Datenschutzpolitik
und will auf eine Datenchancenpolitik setzen.
Weil der nochmal einen anderen Spin hat, das ist ja klar.
Ja, also.
Achso, sollten wir bei der Gelegenheit erwähnen, die haben keine eigenen Programme.
Aline hat jetzt gesagt Union. Die CDU und CSU haben gemeinschaftliche Programme,
sind natürlich eigentlich zwei Parteien, aber die haben auch auf der Webseite
der CDU ein gemeinsames und wechselseitig auf der CSU.
Und also um mal einen Punkt vielleicht auch positiv herauszuheben,
Also wenn man sich ja auch dann immer fragen kann, wem soll denn dieser digitale Staat dienen?
Welche BürgerInnen sind da besonders im Zentrum? Da fand ich das immerhin mal
ganz schön bei den Grünen,
die so etwas überhaupt mal erwähnen, wie antragslose Verfahren und dass leistungsberechtigte
Leistungen auch erhalten sollen und
dass man auch dafür eben halt eine Staatsdigitalisierung nutzen möchte.
Ja, zum Thema digitalen Ministeriumverhalten verhält man sich unterschiedlich.
Wobei auch da das nicht wirklich durchgesprochen wird, nicht richtig klar ist,
was jetzt die konkreten Unterschiede sind.
Also genau, die CDU hätte sehr gerne ein digitales Ministerium, die SPD halt eher nicht.
Aber was sich dann hinterher in der Substanz für Menschen ändert, das bleibt unklar.
Also ich fand es spannend, dass so ein paar ganz konkrete Themen sich durch
alle Programme durchziehen.
Dazu gehört zum Beispiel die Patientenakte, mit der du eben eingeleitet hattest.
Das wollen sie alle, dass die Digitalisierung im Gesundheitswesen vorangeht,
um da auch Forschung und so weiter zu verbessern und Zugang dazu verbessern.
Die E-ID war genau das gleiche oder auch die Bund-ID, die sie alle im Prinzip
zu so einer Art Bürger-ID weiterentwickeln wollen.
Die Deutschland-ID nennen sie es, glaube ich. Eine elektronische Identität,
also eine Form, sich auszuweisen.
Das ist vor allen Dingen eine Zusammenführung auch der Register.
Also ich meine, alles, was an unterschiedlichen Sachen gespeichert wird,
wird über diese ID zentral nutzbar. Und ich meine, wenn man sich jetzt gerade,
was weiß ich, wenn man zwischen den Jahren beim Kongress war oder sowas ähnliches.
Dann hat man die
Probleme sehr gut gesehen in den unterschiedlichen Teilen.
Und im Prinzip sind alle diese Sachen, die einheitlich durch alle gefordert
werden, mit Problemen behaftet.
Mit konkreten Sicherheitsproblemen, typischerweise Datenschutzproblemen oder ähnlichem.
Ich muss mal kurz eine Frage sagen, ist das generell eine gute Idee,
Bürgerdaten aus verschiedenen Datenbanken zu zentralisieren?
Ich dachte, da haben wir so ein bisschen Berührungsengtis.
Kann man generell kritisieren, wurde auch an vielen Stellen kritisiert,
wobei das Zusammenführen per se, glaube ich, gar nicht die große Kritik war.
Wenn man mit einigen Krypto-Experten redet, kann man das ja auch so machen,
dass es trotzdem anonym bleibt oder dass es nicht wirklich zusammengeführt werden
muss, sondern dass man das nur als Pointer verwenden kann. Aber das sind wirklich
jetzt technische Details, so wie es im Moment realisiert worden ist, ist halt ungeschickt.
Aber das zentrale Problem ist ja wirklich, dass diese ganzen Verfahren,
egal ob es jetzt EID, Patientenakte oder sonst was ist, im Moment problembehaftet
sind und einfach nicht sauber implementiert wurden, nicht sauber umgesetzt wurden.
Und dieses Thema wird halt nirgendwo aufgenommen.
Ach ja, das triggert mich so derart, weil das ist natürlich die Untertreibung des Jahrzehnts.
E-ID ist sozusagen der digitale Ausweis und Bund-ID ist sozusagen so eine Art ...
Keine Steuernummer, aber hängen noch viel mehr Sachen dran.
Das darf ja nicht.
Das darf nicht die Person.
Aber im Prinzip führt es aufs Gleiche hinaus.
So konntest du ein bisschen von was?
Nein, also ich werde mal einem Beispiel klar machen, wie verkorkstet ist.
Wir haben jetzt seit mehreren Jahren ein Gesetz, was die gesetzlichen Krankenkassen
verpflichtet, die Patientendaten zusammen zu holen. Nämlich im Forschungsdatenzentrum.
Das ist eine gesetzliche Pflicht. Die kriegen es nicht hin.
2025 läuft dieses Forschungsdatenzentrum immer noch nicht, weil sie technisch
hinkriegen, weil sie kein ordentliches IT-Sicherheitskonzept haben.
Ich führe da so ein Musterverfahren, weswegen ich in größeren Abständen,
also immer nach einem Monat mal wieder erfahre, wie weit sie da sind.
Weil wir das Verfahren ausgesetzt haben, weil sie es nicht hinkriegen.
Wir reden über die Digitalisierung von Gesundheitsdaten und wenn du dir das
praktisch anguckst, das ist unfassbar amateurhaft.
Und wir haben jetzt wieder die Nachricht, dass es kommt dann vielleicht irgendwann 2025.
Es läuft also seit Jahren nichts, weil sie kein sozusagen fertiges Forschungsdatenzentrum haben.
Was jetzt vielleicht der Vollständigkeit halber, weil es nicht alle mitbekommen
haben, auch sagen, auf dem Kongress gab es einen Vortrag zur Nichtsicherheit
der elektronischen Patientenakte.
No, no, no. Die Patientenakte, die kommt jetzt. Das ist ja im Rollout sozusagen.
Ich denke, die ist ausgesetzt. Da hat doch der Herr Lauterbach neulich geäxt.
Das hat er so jetzt ja doch nicht gesagt. Sondern er meinte ja damit nur,
wir fixen alle Probleme.
Aber die Patientenakte hat mit der eigentlichen Ausleitung der Gesundheitsdaten
von allen gesetzlichen Versicherungen gar nichts zu tun.
Das ist richtig.
Das ist schon älter und die kriegen es nicht mal hin.
Der regert mich so derart,
Entschuldigung.
Aber im Wahlprogramm ist überall drin, können wir nochmal zusammenfassen.
Also um den Sidestrack zu beenden, sozusagen mit dem Forschungszentrum,
ja und elektronische Patientenakte, ihr habt noch Zeit, dass ihr ganz persönlich
sozusagen, ihr könnt einfach der elektronischen Patientenakte widersprechen.
Immer mehr Leute fordern das und zwar nicht nur sozusagen die klassischen,
ich möchte meine Daten eigentlich nirgendwo haben, sondern mittlerweile sagen
auch die Ärzte und Ärztinnen und egal. Ja, also könnt ihr doch machen,
bei meiner Krankenkasse ist das sozusagen ein Klick, zwei Klicks,
um fair zu sein. Hast du schon Zahlen,
Die viele gemacht haben?
Nee.
Also es gibt Krankenkassen, die haben schon über 5 Prozent, das fand ich überraschend viel.
Also wir werden noch keine Abstiegs an Zahlen haben. Ich hätte gedacht,
das ist schon zweistellig,
Aber gut. Also man kann jetzt erstmal bei dem Thema festhalten, alle wollen es.
Niemand erwähnt, dass im Konkreten eigentlich alles problembehaftet ist und
nimmt sich sozusagen zum Ziel, das mal irgendwie in den Griff zu bekommen.
Auch hier wieder positiver Aspekt, niemand verspricht Dinge,
die man nicht halten kann.
Wow.
Und ich will aber sozusagen in diesem Themenbereich noch eine andere Sache fragen,
weil eine der großen Forderungen ist ja auch sozusagen, also wenn es um Digitalisierung
geht, geht es immer auch um Datenbereithaltung des Staates, also der maschinenlesbare Staat.
Also dass Registerdaten, also sofern sie von öffentlichem Interesse sind oder
sein sollten, zur Verfügung gestellt werden, dass generell Kommunikation maschinenlesbar
ist und nicht irgendwie ausgedruckte, eingescannte und dann in PDF verpackte Dinge.
Also es gibt, was mir aufgefallen ist, was ich auch fast, weil es Wording so
einheitlich war, durch fast alle Programme war, dass man gesagt hat,
nur einmal Daten irgendwie dem Staat zur Verfügung stellen, nur einmal irgendwo
bereitstellen muss das wechselseitig auslesbar sein,
muss man teilweise auch positiver vielleicht in Form, dass man es selber in
so einer Art Wallet auf dem Handy zusammenführen kann, wo man dann alle Unterlagen
immer dabei hat oder solche Geschichten.
Denn wenn man das unter einem Aspekt sieht, ich habe selber Kontrolle über meine
Daten, ist das vielleicht okay, ich befürchte, dass es so nicht implementiert
werden wird, aber diese grundsätzliche Idee zu sagen,
Verwaltung oder Interaktion mit dem Staat soll einfacher werden,
soll zentraler werden, man soll nicht an tausend Stellen immer wieder alles
neu angeben müssen und so weiter, das habe ich auch überall eigentlich gesehen,
das ist so eine grundsätzliche Idee der Verwaltungsdigitalisierung.
Also ja, aber ich meinte ja eigentlich das andere. Ich meinte ja,
es gibt, der Staat hat ja ganz viele Daten, die, das klassische Beispiel ist
immer Geografiedaten von Ortschaften.
Also nicht persönliche Daten. Ja, genau.
Und das ist ja sozusagen schon lange ein Ziel von digitalem Aktivismus,
auch dass das ermöglicht wird in Zukunft.
Da gibt es ja auch Verknüpfungen. Also Frag den Staat ist ja im Prinzip auch
was, was so eine ganz starke Digitalkomponente hat. Da geht es ja eigentlich
um Transparenz der Abgeordneten.
Aber es hat ja auch die Digitalkomponente, Kommunikationswege und dann öffentlich
analysierbare Antworten und so weiter zu haben. Also dieses Ding sozusagen. Öffentlich...
Daten vom Staat, die von öffentlichem Interesse sind,
in einer maschinenlesbaren Form für jedermann umsonst zur Verfügung zu stellen,
hat das irgendeiner als Ziel oder erwähnt das Thema irgendjemand und sagt,
nee, das wollen wir nicht,
sondern wir wollen, dass die Digitalwirtschaft daraus geile Apps bauen kann und Produkte erzeugt.
Es gibt ja wilde Dinge, die man sich vorstellen kann. Also spielt das Thema irgendwo eine Rolle?
Die Linke erwähnt ein Recht auf Open Data und auch Transparenz gesetzt, glaube ich.
Tatsächlich gibt es sogar Stimmen in der CDU, ich muss mal gucken, was der Wortlaut war.
Die CDU hat das auch drin.
Genau, die sagen Open Data, ich glaube für Innovation und also quasi Open Data
insofern Open Data wirtschaftlich nutzbar ist.
Also sagen, wo nicht dieser Aspekt von einem rechenschaftspflichtigen Verwaltungshandeln
oder sowas im Zentrum steht.
Also, aber es ist sehr zum Randthema geworden, was traurig ist angesichts der
Tatsache, dass das eins der Projekte ist, das bei der Ampel halt auf der Strecke geblieben ist,
Aber bei… Der inklusive Transparenz ist ja auch.
Es wird halt auch ganz klar unter dem Aspekt Wirtschaft geführt.
Also, dass der Wirtschaft die Daten des Staates zur Verfügung stehen,
entweder für eigene Produkte oder für Forschung oder so und so weiter und so fort.
Also, das ist eigentlich die, also da kommt es vor. An so einer anderen Stelle
kommt es eigentlich nicht vor.
Und das ist auch, ich habe so gesehen, weil ich mir auch für einige Landtagswahlen
das schon angesehen hatte, sind auch wortgleich mit Erforderungen,
die sie auch schon bei Landtagswahlen, also jetzt von der CDU, erhoben hatten.
Also da ist jetzt auch nichts Neues, was mir aufgefallen wäre.
Das ist halt nur noch nischiger.
Also wir sind jetzt sozusagen zwei Themen in der Diskussion drin und eigentlich
gibt es noch in keinem Digitalprogramm irgendwo was, wo man sagen könnte,
das könnte einen Ausschlag für eine Wahlentscheidung geben.
Ich habe noch schon ein paar Sachen entdeckt.
Nicht, dass es kommt, aber bis jetzt. Was Sie bis jetzt gesagt haben,
klingt für mich sozusagen ganz komplett nach, also es gibt Schlagworte und die
kennen wir oder nicht und wenn wir die kennen, dann sagen wir,
das wird alles total schön, aber niemand hat einen konkreten Plan bis jetzt.
Stimmt, jetzt hast du doch nur die Themen angesprochen, wo quasi einheitlich
oder wo sie sich nicht wirklich widersprechen.
Na gut, kommen wir mal zum nächsten. IT-Sicherheit und Datenschutz.
Da ist ja mal die Frage, inwiefern also wird das reglementiert?
Datenschutz gibt es natürlich, sagen Datenschutz gegenüber dem Staat,
aber auch sozusagen, wie wird der Datenschutz so reglementiert,
dass Firmen sich auch dran halten müssen?
Und auch die Frage, inwiefern sind Anbieter von Produkten, Plattformen oder
Infrastrukturen zu so einer Art Sicherheit der Informationstechnik verpflichtet?
Also müssen da bestimmte Dinge leisten?
Auch das kann man ja gesetzlich regeln und das hat in der jüngeren Vergangenheit
eine immer größere Rolle gespielt.
Wie sieht es denn hier aus? Hat hier jemand konkrete Vorschläge, da was machen zu wollen.
Also sehr aufgefallen. Es ist mir, was Aline aber schon in dem anderen Aspekt
jetzt angesprochen hat, die Idee von den Konservativen zu sagen,
die sind mit dem Datenschutz, wollen wir jetzt mal nicht mehr so übertreiben.
Das hat man schon nicht so sehr in dem Wahlprogramm, aber auch schon in der
letzten Wahl ein bisschen gesehen.
Das ist mir bei der CDU schon ziemlich aufgefallen. Das wäre aber letztlich
natürlich ein Paradigmenwechsel. Das muss man schon so benennen.
Also sozusagen Datenschutz nicht mehr als Grundrecht,
Sondern… Das ist ja ein Grundrecht, das können Sie ja nur nicht wegdiskutieren.
Also Sie können es umwidmen. Ja, ist mir sehr aufgefallen.
Die Formulierung pragmatischer Datenschutz findet sich aber bei mehreren wieder,
also zum Beispiel auch bei den Grünen.
Und ich glaube bei der CDU ist es mir nochmal besonders aufgefallen im Kontext
von einer Idee, die ich vorher noch nicht kannte, eine Schüler-ID,
die auch einen pragmatischen Datenschutz haben soll.
Was soll das heißen da?
Also das ist im Kontext dann von Schulen. Dort soll es darum gehen,
dass man mehr lernen kann, mehr Forschung darüber,
wie Bildung funktioniert und das dafür eben halt das Lernverhalten von einzelnen SchülerInnen.
Also es ist nicht so klar formuliert, was das genau bedeutet.
Eine super Idee, besonders Schutzbedürftige digital zu analysieren und zu durchleuchten, klar.
Bei Schülern ist klar, was mir bei der CDU da aufgefallen ist,
die haben das so formuliert, dass sie sagen, im Prinzip DSGVO zurückrollen, aber dafür Genau,
dafür aber eine Selbstbestimmung, welche Daten erhoben, verarbeitet und so weiter.
Also der Nutzer soll im Prinzip die Möglichkeit haben, selbst zu bestimmen,
welche Daten erhoben werden, wie sie verarbeitet werden und wenn es weitergegeben wird.
Das
Ich würde jetzt mal auch als Wirtschaftsvertreter sagen, das ist super schwierig
umzusetzen. Wie soll das überhaupt funktionieren?
Da habe ich ja lieber eine DSGVO, wo ich weiß, was geht, was nicht geht,
was erhoben werden darf, wo ich vielleicht um eine Zustimmung an irgendeiner Stelle frage.
Aber nicht an jeder Ecke über jedes Datum, weil wenn man das so ausgestalten
würde, wie es da steht und so ist es mit Sicherheit nicht gemeint,
das muss ich mal ganz klar sagen,
dass man wirklich immer entscheiden könnte als Nutzer, welche Daten werden jetzt
überhaupt erhoben, was wird irgendwo mitgespeichert oder sowas ähnliches,
das entspricht ja überhaupt nicht der momentanen Praxis, das wäre ein nationaler
Alleingang, der weit weg wäre von allem, was weltweit sonst so läuft und was
von irgendeinem der Unternehmen umgesetzt ist. Also völlig illusorischer Ansatz.
Es ist auch sehr knapp, da müsste man ja eigentlich mal ernsthaft überreden, was die da meinen.
Also muss man vielleicht schon auch sagen, das ist eine Kritik in der DSGVO sogar,
dass die Freiwilligkeit solcher Einverständniserklärungen, also wenn ich jetzt
entscheiden kann, dass die zunehmend aus einer psychologischen,
soziologischen Perspektive in Frage gestellt wird, weil die eigentlich nicht stattfindet.
Weil man sich immer in so einem Ohnmachtsverhältnis gegenüber einer großen Plattform
oder halt eben vielleicht auch dem Staat befindet.
Also von daher ist das, sag ich mal, kritisch zu beachten. Aber immerhin was
Konkretes. Wir haben jetzt in einem Wahlprogramm einen konkreten Punkt,
wo man dagegen sein kann.
Oder dafür.
Wenn man denn will. Also du hast jetzt aber wieder zwei Sachen vermischt.
Datenschutz und IT-Sicherheit gehört natürlich zusammen, aber es ist trotzdem
nicht unbedingt das Gleiche.
Um Gottes Willen, es ist nicht das Gleiche. Ich habe es zusammengetan,
Weil das beides Dinge sind,
die also teilweise auch den Staat betreffen, aber sozusagen weil das vor allen Dingen Dinge sind,
wo der Staat, finde ich, die Aufgabe hat per Gesetz das Verhältnis zwischen
der Einzelperson und Institutionen und Firmen zu reglementieren und auch die Chance hat das zu tun.
Und von daher ist es so ein bisschen ähnlich.
Klaus Hüttel den Kopf, nein.
Na, sehr gut.
Ich bin da nicht ganz bei dir. Ich meine, bei IT-Sicherheit geht es ja typischerweise
um Angriffe von außen, um ob jetzt von Hackern, von Organisationen,
von Staaten oder sonst was irgendwo Angriffe gemacht werden.
Wie sicher ist mein Gesamtsystem?
Natürlich auch gegen die Sicherheit der Daten, die ich von Kunden oder sowas
gespeichert habe. Das gehört natürlich da dazu.
Aber es ist trotzdem ein völlig anderer Aspekt, auch eine ganz andere Schutzsache.
Da muss man aber auch mal sagen, da hat sich jetzt schon viel getan.
Da ist viel von der europäischen Ebene gekommen und in der Umsetzung,
was noch nicht umgesetzt ist.
Aber dieses Gesamtkonstrukt, was sich auf europäischer Ebene dann eigentlich
ausgedacht wurde, wenn das alles umgesetzt wäre oder wenn das alles da ist,
dann ist es eigentlich relativ rund und eine deutliche Verbesserung nach dem,
was wir in den letzten Jahren hatten.
Und da kommt nicht mehr viel in den Wahlprogrammen momentan,
weil die alle auf die Umsetzung erstmal von dem, was als Entwürfe schon vorliegt,
jetzt abstellen und eigentlich sagen, wir wollen das umsetzen, wir wollen NIST 2,
also Network Information Security Act 2,
wir wollen CR, also das ist Critical Entity Regulation,
was wir dann als CRITIS-Dachgesetz umgesetzt haben, so diese ganzen Geschichten
und als nächstes, das kommt witzigerweise nicht drin vor, CRA,
also Cyber Resilience Act, wo es dann um Schutz von Endgeräten und solchen Themen geht.
Das kommt witzigerweise in keinem, habe ich in keinem Wahlprogramm gesehen drin
vor, aber dieses Gesamtkonstrukt ist eigentlich schon da.
Da habe ich noch nirgendwo irgendwas gelesen, was einer drüber hinweggehen oder
hinausgehen will oder noch irgendwas machen will in den Wahlprogramm.
Also dann müssen wir es vielleicht klarstellen, weil vielleicht habe ich es
falsch formuliert, vielleicht sozusagen seid ihr into it,
also sozusagen so tief drin, weil wenn ich, also ich mache ja das sozusagen
hier, ich sitze ja aus Perspektive des Wählenden und deswegen,
wenn ich IT-Sicherheit sage, meine ich tatsächlich nicht so sehr die krass fokussierten
Angriffe auf einen Player,
der sich dann davor schützen muss, sondern da meine ich schon sozusagen ich als Einzelperson,
die aus zwei Perspektiven betroffen ist.
Das ist eines, ich habe hier Geräte zu Hause, wir hatten vor Jahren immer die
Diskussion, sollte man es nicht irgendwie vielleicht sogar gesetzlich verbieten,
dass Routerhersteller Standardpasswörter anbieten?
Also sollte man nicht gesetzlich regeln, dass der Stand der Technik,
was Sicherheit angeht für Endverbraucherprodukte, das ist das eine und das andere
ist, ich bin ja eben als wählender Kunde oder Teil von großen Plattformen.
Also meine Daten liegen halt irgendwo und dann spielen diese Angriffe von du
redest sozusagen schon auch eine Rolle, aber aus einer anderen Perspektive.
Da geht es ja nicht darum, wie ist ein Unternehmen geschützt,
sondern geht es darum, wenn ein Unternehmen meine Daten verarbeitet,
muss es auch auf einer technischen Perspektive für die Sicherheit seiner IT-Systeme
angehalten werden und kann da das, also von daher finde ich,
ist IT-Sicherheit und Datenschutz sozusagen verbunden, weil es mich als einzelnen
Menschen, also weil der Staat mir als einzelnen Menschen helft.
Wissen soll, wie das besser klappt.
Völlig in Ordnung. Die Aspekte, die du gerade angesprochen hast,
die sind tatsächlich durch die neue Gesetzgebung schon alle adressiert,
sind alle schon geregelt. Sie sind bei uns noch nicht richtig umgesetzt.
Also europäische Gesetzgebung meint ihr?
Es gibt schon die europäische Gesetzgebung dazu. Sie ist in Deutschland in Teilen
noch nicht umgesetzt und kommt jetzt erst.
Also diese Aspekte sind eigentlich, also aus meiner Sicht,
erst mal so weit adressiert, dass man jetzt erst mal gucken müsste,
wie funktioniert diese Regulierung, muss man dann nochmal nachsteuern,
aber dafür muss man es erstmal umgesetzt haben und eingeführt haben.
Da kommt noch ein bisschen, was weiß ich, Digital Services Act und solche Geschichten
mit rein und so. Nein, aber die kommen auch noch mit rein.
Alina's mal?
Also es...
An vielen Stellen unterscheidet es sich auch da nicht so erheblich.
Vielleicht an der Stelle ist mir aufgefallen, also eine Frage ist ja auch,
welche Daten werden überhaupt erhoben?
Und da ist zum Beispiel das BSW dabei zu sagen, dass das Sammeln und Speichern
von Verhaltensdaten verboten werden soll, was auf jeden Fall schon nochmal eine
Position ist, die die anderen so nicht vertreten.
Das ist natürlich schon auch dann nochmal eine neue Implikation,
also eine weitere Entwicklung im Kontext von Datenschutz ist,
wo man dann sagen kann, okay, dann passiert sowas wie dieser VW-Skandal,
bei dem dann halt deutlich geworden ist, dass viele Daten, die VW gesammelt
hat, die halt viel zu leicht zugänglich waren,
die dürften in so einem Fall halt einfach gar nicht mehr gesammelt werden.
Also für alle, die es sozusagen vielleicht nicht mitbekommen haben,
auf dem Kongress wurde vorgestellt, dass Volkswagen sehr viele Bewegungsdaten
von Fahrzeugen, also Standortdaten gespeichert hat,
die man auch quasi öffentlich einsetzen konnte, wenn man das so sagen will.
Genau, darum geht es.
Ich würde aber gerne schon kurz mal auf so ne Meta-Ebene wechseln,
weil wir ja auch, also zumindest wenn ich so fertig war mit dem Lesen,
hab ich halt auch so Auslassungen nachgedacht, was fehlt eigentlich,
weil das überhaupt nicht adressiert und da ist für mich…
jenseits der Definition, die du jetzt gerade ergeben hast von IT-Sicherheit,
in einem größeren Sinne die ganze IT-Sicherheitskrise, die ich immer noch sehe,
Überhaupt nicht adressiert. Klaus hat natürlich recht.
Wir haben jetzt europäische Regelungen, namentlich und insbesondere für eine
GINES-II-Richtlinie, die sie auch noch umsetzen wollten.
Und sie hatten auch noch im Bundestag dazu den Versuch gestartet.
Und das ging halt dann nicht mehr zeitlich.
Aber der Punkt ist ja, dass diese, insbesondere die Wirtschaft,
vielleicht nicht unbedingt so sehr die Privatpersonen, Aber die Wirtschaft enorm
betreffende Krise, die sich mit jedem Jahr vergrößert.
Die Schadenssummen werden größer, die Art der Angriffe sind exaltierter.
Die sind natürlich auch in dem Sinne, wenn wir jetzt mal an die großen Hacks
denken, die gerade die USA betroffen haben, deren komplette Telekommunikationsinfrastruktur
gerade einmal weggehackt wurde quasi.
Die waren halt in Echtzeit überall drin. Das ist ein Riesenproblem.
Findet sich überhaupt nicht wieder. Ja, also die Schwerpunkte dieser Programme
sind natürlich immer, sind oft im Sozialen natürlich, sind sehr stark in der
Migration, aber wir haben hier ein riesen Problemfeld in der IT,
findet überhaupt nicht statt.
Ja, das ist, der Datenschutz hat wenigstens mal Amoranda erwähnt,
aber sonst, ich habe bei der CDU mal ein bisschen was gefunden zu Kritis,
also zu kritischen Infrastrukturen,
da haben sie so einen ganz merkwürdigen Absatz, sie würden immer noch,
also die CDU jetzt und die CSU gerne mit China arbeiten,
aber man müsse die kritischen Infrastrukturen im Blick haben,
also da sprechen sie so, so eine kleinen, nischigen Probleme in der IT-Sicherheit
an, aber niemand hat eine Antwort auf diese unfassbare Krise, die immer noch anhält.
Und wenn du in mal den Wirtschaftskontext gehst, ist das ein Thema.
Darüber redet die gesamte letzte Jahr und so, findet nicht statt.
Und wird auch sozusagen nicht...
Also so ein typisches Ding, was nicht adressiert wird.
Ich habe langsam immer gedacht, wir hätten die Sendung sehr kurz halten können. Eigentlich egal.
Ich will es nur mal erwähnen. Ich habe jedenfalls auch mal ein bisschen nach
Auslands rumgeguckt. Was fehlt mir da eigentlich?
Da dachte ich so, okay, IT-Sicherheit.
Also genau so, das könnte man jetzt auch als Beispiel nehmen,
das Schwachstellenmanagement. Die alte Koalition hatte versprochen,
dass sie uns Reglungen vorlegt für das Schwachstellenmanagement.
Wie will der Staat also damit umgehen, wenn er IT-Sicherheitslücken in Erfahrung bringt?
Also die ganze Debatte um, darf er hacken, wie lange darf er auf Sicherheitslücken
sitzen, wird nicht mehr adressiert.
Also die Frage sozusagen, der Staat erfährt von einer Sicherheitslücke und dann
gibt es sozusagen die Abwägung zwischen, wir behalten das und hoffen,
niemand sonst erfährt das, weil dann können wir Systeme hacken und überwachen,
die wir vielleicht brauchen.
Oder wir geben es möglichst schnell, möglichst transparent an die Öffentlichkeit
und sorgen dafür, dass es gefixt wird.
Auch die Rolle des BSI, da ist nichts drin.
Da ist die CDU doch ganz klar gewesen, sie wollen Online-Durchsuchung und Zugang
mit Drinks und so weiter jetzt wieder ermöglichen, im Prinzip den Sicherheitsbehörden.
Aber das war nicht nur die CDU, der Vorschlag kam von der Ampel.
Okay, nächstes Thema steht auch exakt so auf meiner Liste, innere Sicherheit und Überwachung.
Da hoffe ich doch jetzt mal auf ein paar konkrete, schöne, knackige Forderungen,
Staatstrojaner für alle oder so etwas.
Das haben wir doch schon.
Da unterscheiden sich ein bisschen die Parteien.
Wie sieht es denn mit der Vorratssatzspeicherung aus? Gibt es noch irgendeine
Partei, die valide und plausibel gegen eine Vorratssatzspeicherung ist?
Ja, die Grünen und die FDP. Die Grünen? Ja, die Grünen, ja.
Ja, nach wie vor.
Das ist explizit im Wahlprogrammstehen.
Okay, ich bin überrascht. Wie glaubwürdig haltet ihr das?
Ich würde mal sagen, solange das Büro von Notz da noch am Drücker ist,
schon, ja, also die haben sich da sehr stark für gemacht.
Konstantin Notz, Bundestagsabgeordneter, langjähriger Experte in der Digitalpolitik.
Ja, aber also wir haben ja gerade so ein aktuelles Beispiel,
das haben jetzt vielleicht viele mitbekommen, die jetzt den Podcast hören,
weil es erst ein paar Tage zurückliegt, also ja,
die Regierungssprecherin, der sozusagen Restampel hatte ja angekündigt,
dass man sich auf eine neue Speicherpflicht geeinigt hätte, offenbar mit Bezug zu IP-Adressen.
Was die Grünen halt nicht hinkriegen ist, dann zu sagen, nee, nicht mit uns.
Alle haben irgendwie gewartet, dass die mal eine Mitteilung machen,
weil im Koalitionsvertrag was anderes steht, weil in ihrem Parteiprogramm was
anderes steht, nämlich keine anlasslose Massenüberwachung.
Aber irgendwie kriegen die das halt nicht hin zu kommunizieren.
Ich meine, die Frage ist ja, was heißt glaubwürdig?
Also wie viel, wie sehr setzen sie sich dafür ein?
Ich glaube, es ist unwahrscheinlich, dass die Grünen die stärkste Partei werden,
die irgendwie in der Regierung sowas vorgeben können.
Und das heißt, wenn sie mit anderen zusammengehen, also...
Ne, glaube ich genau das, was Konz sagt. Also wenn die SPD jetzt sagen würde,
wir sind gegen die Vorwärtsleiterin, dann würde ich einfach laut anfangen zu
lachen. Weil das wäre halt...
Du, die SPD hat auch ein Positionspapier, was das G. Esken entworfen hat,
die sich auch abgrenzen von Massenüberwachung.
Ja, aber die SPD hat halt auch eine Innenministerin, die gerade massiv dabei ist.
Die stand schon so ein bisschen gegen die Partei jetzt auch in der letzten Legislatur.
Also die haben so einen Graben in der Partei.
So Innenleute, die Innenleute und Faeser wollten das und andere Bereiche,
gerade die Digitalpolitiker und Parteiführung und so wollten es nicht.
Aber verzeiht mir sozusagen, wenn ich das dann sozusagen vereinfache und banalisiere
und zuspitze und populisiere, aber…
Eine Partei, die gerade regierende Partei war in der letzten Legislaturperiode
und versprochen hat, keine Vorratsdatenspeicherung, die eine Frau zur Innenministerin
macht, die dann sagt, Vorratsdatenspeicherung, die ist für mich nicht mehr glaubwürdig.
Egal, was da für interne Grabenkämpfe stattfindet. Also wenn das die Entscheidung
wäre, an der ich meine Wahlentscheidung, ist es nicht.
Aber wenn es so wäre, dann würde ich sagen, ich glaube der SPD das nicht.
Sie steht ja jetzt im Wahlprogramm drin, dass sie es wollen. Gut.
Jetzt haben sie sozusagen eine klarere Linie da gezogen und das ist zwar so
ein bisschen verklausuliert, sie erwähnen nämlich Vorratsdatenspeicherung nicht.
IP und Port kommen vor. Ja genau.
Aber es ist ganz klar gemeint, ist Einführung von Vorratsdatenspeicherung.
Auch für die SPD, denn die SPD hat genau das für den letzten Wahlkampf nicht gemacht.
Das ist ja schon für mich auch ein großer Unterschied.
So, und jetzt will ich sozusagen zurück zu den Grünen kommen.
Da meine ich glaubwürdig sozusagen, es ist leider politische Realität,
mit der ich mich nie anfronten kann, aber wahrscheinlich mal sollte,
dass man nicht alle Forderungen durchsetzen kann, wenn man nicht die Haupt sozusagen groß ist.
Aber trotzdem ist für mich eine Partei glaubwürdig, wenn sie halt sagt,
wir wollen das nicht und dann sozusagen so viel Stress wie geht macht. Das ist meine Frage.
Das hat aber dann doch eher die FDP gemacht in der Ampel, muss man schon sagen.
Die FDP waren diejenigen, die sich laut und vernehmlich gegen die Vorratssprechung
gewährt haben und die letztlich auch den Gesetzentwurf aus dem Justizministerium
für Quick Freeze, was ja eine Alternative ist. Wir verweisen auf das alte Chaosradio.
Also da waren die Grünen zwar, glaube ich, sie haben nie gegen ihr Programm
agiert, aber lauter waren aus meiner Sicht die Liberalen.
Genau, die Grünen haben glaube ich, korrekt wäre glaube ich zu sagen,
sie haben leise am Koalitionsvertrag gearbeitet, also im Rahmen des Koalitionsvertrags
gearbeitet, ohne es aber an die große Glocke zu hängen.
Also das ist ja auch die Frage, was machst du zu deinem Thema,
was machst du zu deinem Kern und das würde ich bei den Grünen nicht sagen.
Die haben sich jetzt nicht als…
Ja, so die digitalen Bürgerrechte profiliert und tun sie jetzt letztlich auch nicht.
Das Programm ist aus meiner Sicht, wenn ich jetzt mal so im Ganzen drauf gucke,
das hat ja ganz klare Schwerpunkte, die sich von allen unterscheiden.
Nämlich also die haben so Nachhaltigkeitsschwerpunkte, aber das ist auch ein
ganz stark wirtschaftliches Programm.
Auch die Digitalthemen haben sehr viele wirtschaftliche Aspekte und so diese
digitalen Bürgerrechte finden letztlich am Rande statt.
Die Schwerpunkte, finde ich, bei Grün liegen woanders. Ist ja auch fair und fair.
Können sie ja machen. Ist mir nur auf jeden Fall auch im Vergleich zu dem,
wie sie sich früher mal aufgestellt haben.
Darüber, also neben dem Thema Vorratsdatenspeicherung gehen aber CDU und SPD
dann noch darüber hinaus.
Also sozusagen verwenden digitale Technologien, um den Staat sozusagen in Sicherheitsfragen,
wie sie formulieren würden, wahrscheinlich besser aufzustellen.
Also die CDU will auch KI in Gerichten einsetzen. Das war mir neu. Fuck.
Na, aber natürlich.
Und damit, Zitat, das Personal zu entlasten,
das ist die, also ja, wir wissen, was KI macht, zumindest die KI in der aktuellen
Form und die SPD befürwortet aber explizit auch nochmal KI für die Polizei.
Also auch dort, ich meine, wir wissen, dass KI einfach Diskriminierungsmuster
perpetuiert und nicht dazu beiträgt, eine gerechtere Gesellschaft zu bauen.
Die Union hat das auch, explizit.
Genau, explizit, auch KI-Einsatz, auch zum Bildabgleich mit allem,
was in Polizeidatenbanken, in Social Media und so weiter geschwindet ist.
Interessanterweise, die gehen ja noch einen Schritt weiter, die CDU hat explizit
drinstehen, dass sie einen Datenabgleich zwischen den einzelnen Behörden wollen,
also auch zwischen Finanzämtern, Polizeien, sonst was, lalala, also alles komplett,
zoll und so, alle sollen einen Datenabgleich untereinander,
diese Möglichkeit soll geschaffen werden, was momentan so in dieser Form nicht geht.
Und wenn ich dann noch den KI-Einsatz und auch den KI-Einsatz für Text und andere,
also sprich das, was wir jetzt in Hessen und Bayern schon hatten,
wo wir ja diverse Klagen es dagegen gab.
Die laufen auch noch.
Genau, Palantier-Geschichten und so.
Also auch um das nochmal ganz klar zu sagen, KI ist ein großes Thema jetzt in
den letzten Jahren gewesen und die Einhellige, auch Leute, die dafür sind,
Meinung sagen, KI kann nicht fehlerfrei agieren.
Und deswegen sozusagen technisch-algorithmische Systeme, egal ob KI oder nicht,
an sowas zu setzen, nämlich an Rechtsprechung oder an sozusagen die Unterscheidung,
wer ist verdächtig und wird überwacht und wer nicht, das ist schon mehr als fahrlässig.
KI ist ja eines der großen Buzzwords in allen, also eigentlich in allen Programmen.
Lass uns da gleich noch kommen, ich würde noch zu einer anderen Sache fragen.
Bei digitaler Überwachung gibt es ja auch so Staatstrojaner,
Kameraüberwachung, Gesichtserkennung, spielt sowas eine Rolle?
Sekunde, bevor du zu den Staatstrojanern kommst, ich will zwei Sachen schon nochmal erwähnen.
Wir haben bei KI einen Polizeieinsatz, also insbesondere Palantir,
aber mittlerweile gibt es auch andere Anbieter, die Analyse-Tools für die Polizei anbieten.
Wir haben ein verfassungsgerichtliches Urteil, Februar 2023.
Da kratzen sie natürlich schon wieder dran. Wir haben ein aktuelles Urteil zur Inpol.
Das ist die Verbunddatei der Polizeien und wie man die auswerten darf.
Das ist schon wieder alles hart an der Verfassungswidrigkeit,
was da steht im CDU-CSU-Programm.
Man muss sich ja auch vergegenwärtigen, dass wir da schon juristische Kämpfe hatten.
Wir haben Ausfragen und die lange Urteile, auch dieses erste KI-Urteil mit dem
Palantir-Urteil, da sind die hart dran.
Das ist schon eine deutlich andere Agenda als die anderen Parteien.
Und mit der Aufnahme, Klaus hat es eben kurz erwähnt, dass eben auch die Biometrie
mit drin ist, das ist schon qualitativ der Hammer.
Man kann aus meiner Sicht sehr klar sagen, im Bereich der Daten,
auch Massendatenauswertung und der KI ist die CDU ganz weit weg.
Und da ist noch ein Punkt, der mir auf die Meta-Ebene wechselnd.
Die haben die Sicherheit als Schwerpunkt, anders als alle anderen Parteien,
die nennen das auch so, aber die verstehen Sicherheit wirklich nur im Sinne
von Datensammeln und Analysieren.
Also diese ganzen präventiven Ansätze, Sicherheits kann man ja ganz anders verstehen.
Also wie man was sicher macht, haben die überhaupt nicht drin.
Das ist also ein ganz klarer Polizeigewerkschaftsding.
Das finde ich ist qualitativ ein riesen Unterschied zu allen anderen Parteien.
Entschuldigung, jetzt habe ich dich, also ich wollte nur mal,
mir ist so aufgefallen, dass die...
Die Dienste sollen auch gestärkt werden. Das ist auch ein ganz entscheidender Punkt.
Und die Kontrolle zurückgefahren werden bei den Geheimdiensten.
Also da schon echt. So agiert niemand von den anderen demokratischen Parteien.
Und wie ist es jetzt mit noch anderen Sachen? Eben Biometrie,
Gesichtserkennung, Kamera, flächendeckte Kameraüberwachung und so weiter und so fort.
Union sagt ja, ganz eindeutig.
Sagt irgendjemand klar nein?
Die FDP ist gegen Gesichtserkennung.
FDP komplett, ja. Die waren eindeutig dagegen.
Und die Grünen grundsätzlich auch nicht, aber
ich glaube, so ein paar Kriminalitätsschwerpunkten wollten sie da Abstand.
Also da konnten sie sich das irgendwie vorstellen, aber im Prinzip nicht.
Und insbesondere auch der Abgleich
mit einer Datenbank oder Social Media und sowas war da nicht drin.
Und bei den Staatsrägern ist es natürlich im Prinzip bezüglich,
Das ist zur absoluten Nische geworden.
Du musstest auch ziemlich suchen, weil sie das ja mittlerweile unter Telefonüberwachung
auch so summieren, weil ja ein Teil der Staatsräner unter diesem Begriff Quellenticker gefällt.
Du musstest also auch suchen und die ganzen Skandale, die ja in die letzte Legislatur
fielen auch, also um Staatsräner, findet alles nicht statt.
Eigentlich müsstest du ja ein Wahlprogramm suchen, zumindest wenn du dich an
der Ampel orientierst und im Koalitionsvertrag, wie sie das wieder eindämmen wollen.
Das findet letztlich nicht mehr statt. Das ist wirklich krass.
Dann habe ich noch zwei Sachen, die in den Bereich fallen. Das eine ist Chatkontrolle.
Also es gibt ja sozusagen auf EU-EU immer wieder Bestrebungen,
Verschlüsselung aufzubrechen.
Alles andere ist Anonymisierung oder Anonymität im Internet.
Es gibt auch immer wieder Bestrebungen in verschiedenen Arten und Weisen,
ob das überhaupt noch möglich sein soll oder nicht.
Verhält sich da irgendwie jemand zu?
Ja, als Quellen-EU, ja. Das ist ja genau das. Nee, nee. Kommt das ja dran für.
Nee, das, okay.
Du meinst jetzt Client-Side-Scanning oder so.
Genau, es gibt ja sozusagen unter dem Namen gibt es ja, also die Quellenticker
ist ja sozusagen, wir nehmen die beschlechtigten Systeme und dürfen da einbrechen.
So und dann gibt es ja auch die,
Das andere sind Frontdoors.
Genau, das andere ist sozusagen, du darfst als Hersteller keine Verschlüsselung
mehr anbieten oder du darfst als Privatperson nicht mehr verschlüsseln.
Also das fordert ja eigentlich keiner mehr. Es geht nur darum,
dass du in die Software Frontdoors einbaust, also Sachen, die mit einem Schlüssel,
so einer Art Nachschlüssel, das dann überwacht werden kann oder ausgeleitet
werden kann aus der Software.
Aber das ist so ein bisschen Potatoes, Potatoes, also weil die...
Das ist was anderes, die Übertragung und die eigentliche, du hast immer noch
eine sichere, in Anführungszeichen, Ende-zu-Ende-Verschlüsselung,
nur die Enden sind nicht mehr sicher. Also das ist schon nochmal ein Unterschied, ja.
Für mich als Privatperson ist ja die interessante Frage, der Message,
die ich benutze, kann ich mich auf den verlassen oder ist in dem an irgendeiner
Stelle geplant eingebaut, dass die Dinge, die ich da betreibe,
ausgeleitet werden und das ist für mich sozusagen,
wenn ich Verschlüsselung sage, man kann das dann politisch und technisch sozusagen
komplexer diskutieren,
denke ich.
Und es ist in der Tat natürlich technisch ein Riesenunterschied zwischen der
Datenstrom wird entschlüsselt und auf meinem Gerät passieren Dinge,
aber es kommt ja aufs selbe sozusagen heraus. Es geht um Vertraulichkeit der Kommunikation.
Also A, so konkret werden sie nicht.
Man muss sich ja klar machen, dass auf europäischer Ebene bei der Chatkontrolle
geht es ja, also der Zweck dieser Regelung ist ja eigentlich der Schutz vor
Gewalt. Ja, also da geht es ja um Kindesmissbrauch letztlich.
Sag mal. Ja, naja, man muss da schon mal sagen, was die Idee des Chat-Kontrolle-Gesetzentwurfs ist.
Kann man technisch stark kritisieren, aber diese Forderung, die ist natürlich
drin, aber es wird nicht so konkret, dass man sagen will, mit welchen technischen Mitteln.
Die Kritik an der Chat-Kontrolle ist ja vor allen Dingen, dass sie damit in
hohem Maße die IT-Sicherheit unterminieren. Und das sind ja sehr viele technische
Argumente und so klar wird es in dem Wahlprogramm nicht.
Jetzt möchte ich mal sozusagen wortglauberisch werden, weil ich finde nicht
die Idee der Chatkontrolle ist der Schutz von Kindern, sondern …
Es wird gesagt, das sei die Idee. Das kann und sollte man, glaube ich,
sozusagen stark hinterfragen.
Ja, und also Chatkontrolle erwähnen ablehnend FDP und Linke,
interessante Allianz hier an der Stelle.
Aber ohne technische Details.
Genau, und also alle sagen halt auch sowas wie, wir müssen Kinder,
Jugendliche besser beschützen.
Ich würde jetzt nicht so weit gehen, zu sagen, damit legitimieren sie zwangsläufig die Chatkontrolle.
Was wir aber zum Beispiel sehen, sind auch Ideen wie Altersverifikation bei der SPD.
Da wissen wir halt auch, mir ist kein Ansatz bekannt, mit dem man vernünftig
Alter verifizieren kann, ohne nicht die Anonymität in einem signifikanten Maße aufzuheben online.
Also super schwierig an der Stelle.
Es wird in Australien gerade diskutiert, ob man das mit KI macht.
Also sagen die KI analysiert die Person, die da am Gerät ist und sagt dann, ja.
Ja, es wird ja immer besser.
Ja, natürlich.
Wir müssen es nur mal kurz sagen, falls jemand den Zynistus mitkriegt,
das ist eine bekloppte Idee. Also nur mal kurz, um es zu explizieren.
Oh, come on.
Nein, ich weiß ja, dass ich kein Freund davon bin. Es ist halt die,
ich kann den grundsätzlichen Ansatz dahinter schon verstehen,
wenn man sagt, wir machen Strafverfolgung, wir wissen, da gibt es Probleme.
Aber ich habe Anbieter, die nicht kooperieren, also wo gar nichts passiert,
wo ich weiß, da ist verschlüsselte Kommunikation in riesengroßen Gruppen mit,
was weiß ich, 100.000 Leuten und da wird sozusagen Kinderponografie drin geteilt
oder irgendetwas Ähnliches, das ist bekannt.
Ich komme da einfach nicht ran. Ich komme einfach nicht weiter.
Selbst eine klassische Telekommunikation nützt mir nichts, was alles verschlüsselte Kommunikation.
Also ich kann den grundsätzlichen Ansatz, der dahinter steht,
durchaus nachvollziehen.
Die technische Probleme, die damit entstehen, die Unsicherheit der ganzen Geräte
und ich kriege das ja nicht gesichert.
Das ist völlig egal, wie ich versuche, diesen Zugang zu dieser Software,
zu diesem Gerät dann zu sichern.
Es sollen ja Strafverfolger da drauf. Und Strafverfolger ist ja nicht eins.
Das sind im Zweifelsfall, in Deutschland wären es Dutzende. Wir haben allein.
160 Staatsanwaltschaften oder sowas am Start. Und dann, es gibt ja auch noch
andere Länder. Wie will ich denn das regulieren? Da dürfen das jetzt die Deutschen.
Kann ich das in Europa? Kann ich das in den USA? Kann ich das in China raus?
Aus Ländern, denen ich das nicht zutraue?
Es ist einfach nicht sicher, aber in dem Moment, wo mehr als eine Handvoll Kies
draußen sind, wird das sowieso irgendwo missbraucht, ist nicht mehr kontrolliert.
Man hat keine Zugangskontrolle mehr auf diese Sache. Das heißt,
es ist im Prinzip alles offen.
Es ist keine Nachschlüssel mehr für irgendwas. Es ist einfach offen.
Und deswegen ist es natürlich prinzipiell abzulehnen. Völlig egal,
wie kritisch, wie problematisch es dieser Phänomenbereich ist.
Man muss immer ganz am Anfang schon vorsichtig sein.
Egal, was man da macht, das verhindert keinen Missbrauch an Kindern.
Das verhindert vielleicht und nur vielleicht die Verteilung von Bildmaterial
dass das beim Missbrauch von Kindern entstanden ist.
Genau, also ich finde das, also ich würde auch, sorry, also würde ganz,
ganz stark betonen wollen, dass es nicht nur ein Problem der IT-Sicherheit ist,
sondern zum einen, also dass es dann wirklich bei Kinderpornografie bliebe,
dass dann die Strafbehörden darauf Zugriff bekommen.
Also da muss man schon sehr gutwillig sein, um das zu glauben.
Und der andere Punkt, genau Markus, den du jetzt angesprochen hast,
ist das wirklich ein effektives, verhältnismäßiges Mittel, mit dem wir vernünftig
gegen den Problem von Kindermissbrauch vorgehen.
Ich meine, dazu gibt es auch Studien. Ich finde dieses Narrativ ganz,
ganz schwierig zu sagen.
Chatkontrolle, das ist da nicht nur vorgeschobenerweise um Kinderschutz.
Da habe ich zwei Antworten für dich. Wir betreiben ja auch eine Beschwerdestelle
und haben als Eko ziemlich tief in diesem Bereich. Länger noch, ja.
Und also man unterschätzt, wie viel in diesem ganzen Bereich auch auf Anforderungen
passiert, live, Videostreaming, sonst was, das gibt es da alles.
Also es ist nicht nur, wenn du sagst, man schützt damit keine Kinder,
das ist nicht richtig. Aber ich möchte gar nicht dem das Wort reden,
weil du hast, der entscheidende Punkt hast du danach gesagt,
das ist einfach nicht verhältnismäßig.
Und es ist völlig egal, man wird das damit nicht in den Griff kriegen und damit
ist es auch schon unverhältnismäßig.
Man gefährdet alle, man gefährdet die komplette IT-Sicherheit im weitesten Sinne,
weil das ist dann die Backdoor, die von Gott in der Welt verwendet werden kann.
Das war auch geschehen, das haben wir auch gerade erlebt. Ende des Jahres,
das ist ja gerade der Fortwall in den USA, das ist ja genau benutzt worden.
Kannst du kurz konkretisieren?
Der Schlagwort dafür ist Salt Typhoon. Also es ist sozusagen die Nutzung durch
Dritte, in diesem Fall wurde die Chinesen sozusagen, als Angreifer sind die
Chinesen identifiziert worden.
Dass sie eben solche Überwachungsschnittstellen, Lawful Interception-Schnittstellen
ausgenutzt haben. Das heißt, wenn man Hintertüren baut, benutzen sie nicht nur die Guten.
Ach stimmt, da wurde ja nicht irgendwie auf...
Und so richtig alle, so Verizon, AT&T, sie haben neun große Anbieter mittlerweile. Also das ist einfach...
Da ging es um klassische Telekommunikationsunternehmen, die dann aufgerufen
haben, man soll Signal benutzen, weil alles andere sozusagen gerade ungekehrt ist.
AI hat gesagt, man soll encrypted Kommunikation werden.
Also großes Thema, ich halte mal fest, es gibt sozusagen so wenig Überraschung,
die Spaltung, dass die Union denkt so voll gut, lass mal irgendwie alles überwachen.
SPD eher so, lass mal alles überwachen. Grüne eher so, lass mal nicht überwachen,
aber wir können nicht garantieren, dass wir da so viel machen können irgendwie.
Also dafür, dass du sie nicht gelesen hast, hast du dir einen Zoom zusammengefasst.
Also ich möchte, nur weil wir in dem Bereich gerade sind, das ist jetzt nicht
direkt die Wahlprogramme, aber dieser ganze Bereich, der auch in der Politik
ja überall wieder hochgespielt wird, der ist absolut verzerrt.
Und der ist verzerrt durch NECMAC. Also das ist die amerikanische Meldestelle,
das ist die amerikanische Meldestelle für NECMAC, also so nennt man es. Das ist ja NECMAC.
Also dort werden im Prinzip Funde bei amerikanischen Freunden,
auch in Social Media, in sonst was,
irgendwas gemeldet und das wird dann weitergegeben bei uns an das BKA.
Und dadurch kommen ich glaube es lässt sich halt mal um die 70.000,
80.000 Fälle hier rein. Also 10.000.
10.000, ja, die da reinkommen, die werden dann versucht weiterzufolgen.
Das führt zu zwei Sachen.
Aha, der Phänomenbereich ist overplayed, also wenn man nur die deutschen Fälle
im Prinzip nehmen würde, wäre es viel, viel weniger, ein weniger Bruchteil davon
und wäre auch wesentlich langsamer gewachsen.
Und das zweite ist, da kommt dieser Vorratsdatenspeicherungssing,
weil die kommen dann mit Verzögerungen an und alles, was die bekommen,
ist eine IP-Adresse und seit November letztes Jahr eine IP-Adresse und ein Port
und dann will man das auflösen und es sind keine Daten.
Also da kommt diese Vorratsdatenspeicherung-Diskussion wieder mit auf,
weil man ja diese riesen Zahlen hat, die man nicht weiterverfolgen kann.
Aber das ist nichts, was so diese klassische Weiterentwicklung von Kriminalität
ist, wie wir es hatten, sondern es ist eine direkte Folge gewesen von diesen
Meldeverpflichtungen, die man auch in den USA eingeführt hat, in Social Media,
in Chatgruppen und so weiter und so fort, wo also die Anbieter das weitergeben müssen.
Das ist so ein bisschen vergleichbar mit dem, was wir im NetzDG hatten,
mit Meldepflichten und solchen Geschichten.
Also man muss deswegen auch immer ganz klar sagen, was passiert dann?
Was passiert mit etwas, was konkrete Polizeiarbeit ist, wo etwas weitergegeben wird?
Was kommt dann in der Politik an? Was wird verstanden, wie sich eigentlich etwas entwickelt hat?
Und zum Beispiel in diesem Bereich Vorratsdatenspeicherung sind wir dann ganz
schnell bei dem Problem.
Die Zahlen, die verwendet werden, sind einfach falsch, weil wie viel kann aufgeklärt werden?
Kommt noch aus der Zeit, als nur IP-Adressen ohne Ports gemeldet wurden seit
November letzten Jahres, hat sich das komplett umgedreht, weil die Ports mit
reinkommen, aber alle Statistiken, die in der Politik verwendet werden,
sind auch die alten Statistiken mit niedriger Aufklärungsquote,
obwohl die Aufklärungsquote mittlerweile sich ins absolute Gegenteil verkehrt hat.
Also es sind nicht mehr 80 Prozent nicht aufzuklären, sondern es sind 90 Prozent
aufklärbar, weil jetzt die Ports mitgeliefert werden.
Was heißt das? Was heißt, wir fordern Vorratssammenspeicherung,
ohne dass wir es eigentlich müssten?
Genau, aber was genau, also Port, das ist immer ein bisschen schwierig zu erklären,
also die IP-Adresse ist die Hausnummer, das Internetanschluss und der Port ist
quasi die Öffnung im Haus, also die Vorder- oder Hintertür.
Ohne Port wäre ich nicht reingekommen.
Entschuldigung. Genau, davon gibt es dann halt irgendwie ein paar tausend potenziell.
Und am Port kann man so sagen, am ehesten erkennen, welcher Dienst es war oder
warum erhöht das die Aufklärung?
Das Problem entsteht durch CarrierNet, also wenn Network Address Translation
nach außen verwendet wird,
dann wirst du ja übersetzt, du kriegst aber nicht nur eine IP-Adresse Übersetzung,
sondern es werden ja mehrere Nutzer sind dann auf einer IP-Adresse und wenn
du den Port nicht mitlieferst, dann kannst du als Anbieter das nicht rückauflösen.
Du kannst nicht sagen, es war der und der Kunde, weil es waren hunderte oder
sogar tausende Kunden gleichzeitig, die diese IP-Adresse verwendet haben.
Und deswegen war das so elementar und es hat jahrelange Arbeit.
Ich war da auch beteiligt, wie kostet das.
Der Port macht das sozusagen einfacher, die konkrete Verbindung nach sowas.
Macht es überhaupt möglich, dass du als Anbieter sagen kannst, es war der Kunde.
Okay, jetzt sind wir sehr tief in die Ziele.
Naja, aber das ist schon immer wichtig zu sagen.
Okay, das ist natürlich ein komplexes Thema, aber ich finde,
Klaus hat den Punkt ja gemacht.
Der Punkt ist, es ist unglaublich overblown und erfasst nicht,
was eigentlich jetzt die technische Realität ist und zwar auch schon wieder seit Monaten,
sondern es ist eine überspitzte Definition, die auch immer nur bei der Überwachung
ansetzt als Antwort und andere Bereiche total auslässt, was man ja auch tun
könnte, zum Beispiel auch präventiv.
Und insofern, also, du kannst dich halt immer hinschauen als Partei,
ja Kinderschutz und so, ja, da sind alle dabei, aber wenn du da mal intensiv
drüber nachdenkst, auch doch die neuesten technischen Entwicklungen siehst,
ja, dann stellt sich das in einem anderen Licht da.
Aber nichts davon bildet sich in der politischen Diskussion ab.
Die Frage wird sein, ob sie letztlich, die entscheidende Frage wird sein,
wie sich Deutschland nach der Wahl in der Chatkontrolle in Europa positioniert.
Denn Deutschland, dadurch, dass sie bisher ablehnend war gegenüber diesem sozusagen
Massenscan, spielt eine wichtige Rolle für diese sogenannte Sperrenminorität.
Also werden es genügend Länder in Europa sein und Deutschland ist nun mal auch wichtig.
Dann jetzt nochmal, welche Parteien sind dagegen?
FDP und Linke.
Ja, also keine, die regierungsmäßig ...
Gegen Chatkontrolle sind die Grünen auch. Das ist klar.
Aber CDU ist dafür, muss man so sagen. SPD habe ich jetzt gerade nicht transparent.
Wahrscheinlich wieder split durch die Parteien. Sie haben es deswegen nicht
drinstehen. Deswegen habe ich im Moment kein klares ...
Wir haben gelernt, also viele interessante Dinge im Detail, aber wir haben vor
allen Dingen gelernt, Und die Wahlprogramme für die nächste Bundestagswahl sind
nicht nur, wie noch nicht ganz fertig gemachte Hausaufgaben, sie sind auch veraltet.
Na gut, das sind sie natürlich immer, das ist tatsächlich jetzt ja auch eine
relativ neue Entwicklung.
Lass mir doch den einen Punkt. Ich habe nämlich noch zwei Sachen sozusagen in
diesen Themenfeldern. Das eine ist Plattformstrategien.
Es gibt ja auf EU-Ebene mit dem Digital Services Act, dem Digital Markets Act,
mittlerweile Gesetzgebung.
Die ist extra dafür gemacht, um mit einem neuen Problem umzugehen,
also einem historisch gesehen neuen Problem, nämlich, dass es Digitalkonzerne
gibt, die eine so große Macht haben,
dass sie quasi supranational sind, also wie eigene Akteuren auf Staatsebene
fast schon regieren. Das wird immer schlimmer.
Also gerade heute am Tag der Aufnahme hat Meta angekündigt, es würde jetzt nicht
mehr mit Faktcheckern zusammenarbeiten wollen und überhaupt dürfe man jetzt
auch alles sagen, ähnlich wie auf X.
Das hat Mark Zuckerberg nicht gesagt, das ist meine Interpretation.
Und es gibt aber eben in der EU diesen regulatorischen Ansatz,
man sagt, wir haben das Problem erkannt, es gibt diese riesigen Plattformen
und weil die so riesig sind, sind die ein Problem und brauchen deswegen extra Regelungen.
Also Bundestagswahl, 23. Februar
2025. Welche Partei verhält sich oder verhalten sich die Parteien dazu?
Haben die sozusagen große Plattformen als Problem, das angegangen und immer
in Betracht gehalten werden muss, erkannt oder ist es einfach ausgelassen?
Das gilt nicht recht. Also das ist deshalb auch kein Schwerpunkt.
Also Sie sagen dazu, oder ich finde es gibt da eigentlich noch ein paar ganz interessante Nuancen.
Also zum einen spricht die CDU zum Beispiel viel davon, dass Dinge souverän werden sollen.
Also es dann immer so ein bisschen heißt, man soll eigene Cloud und Rechenkapazitäten
aufbauen, um sich da zu lösen.
Gleichzeitig sagen sie aber interessanterweise, also es gibt im deutschen Wettbewerbsrecht
so einen Artikel, der auch ein bisschen anders ausgestaltet ist als dieser Digital
Markets Act, der eben halt vor allem auf die Wettbewerbsthemen schaut.
Da haben sie eine Formulierung drin, die sehr nahe legt, dass sie im Grunde
genommen diesen Artikel abschaffen wollen und sozusagen da die Entwicklung des
Kartellrechts in Deutschland zurückdrehen wollen.
Fand ich zumindest eine bemerkenswerte Inkonsistenz.
Und die anderen sagen halt vor allem, ja, DMA, DSA setzen wir durch.
Die einzige Ausnahme hier, die mir aufgefallen ist, ist die Linke,
die auch davon spricht, dort Zerschlagungen durchsetzen zu wollen und eben halt
überhaupt das Problem der Monopolisierung auf den digitalen Märkten viel präsenter diskutiert.
Bei den anderen ist es eher dieses, ja, wir finden das nicht gut,
aber wir haben ja Gesetze, auch wenn die eben halt ja bisher wirklich noch keine
nennenswerten Effekte entfaltet haben.
Und eins ist vielleicht ein bisschen, also die Transparenzanforderung,
das ist, was man jetzt schon sehen kann.
Es gibt ja auch, damit gehen so einige Transparenz- und Berichtspflichten einher.
Da kann man jetzt mal reingucken, das ist mal interessant.
Und sie haben so ein bisschen mehr Zugang zu Forschungsdaten.
Also wer jetzt damit forschen will, da ist auch schon was passiert.
Aber letztlich ist es relativ neu und es ist schon Geltnisrecht.
Insofern kann ich verstehen.
Aber die Aufsicht ist ja noch nicht richtig am Laufen, das kommt ja noch.
Ich habe jetzt, weil ich das schon ein paar Mal gesagt habe,
als jemand, der eine Wahlentscheidung treffen will.
Es ist mir zu wenig, wenn man sagt, das Thema ist geklärt.
Also im Sinne von, da gibt es EU, das ist mir zu wenig, sondern ich möchte,
dass die Partei, die sich bei mir um meine Stimme bewirbt, ich möchte,
dass sie sagt, folgenden Standpunkt haben wir da.
Und bei EU-Gesetzgebung ist ja tatsächlich immer noch die Frage,
also egal, ob das dann etwas ist, was noch im deutschen Recht umgesetzt werden
muss oder ob das dann sofort gilt, aber eben auf die Einhaltung geguckt werden
muss, da kann man sich ja auch zu verhalten, wie streng man das macht.
Von daher kommt meine Frage und von daher ist mir das sozusagen nicht so ganz
genug, wenn man sagt, ja, gibt's ja schon.
Es ist umgesetzt, um das erstmal zu sagen, digitale Dienstgesetz haben wir jetzt,
und es hat jetzt aber keiner gesagt, wir wollen es aufheben oder sowas ähnliches,
Das steht in einigen Programmen explizit drin, dass das jetzt umgesetzt werden soll und dass man die,
das will, was zu einem interessanten Spannungsfeld führt mit dem,
was jetzt in den USA gerade passiert, weil es ist jetzt in solchen Diensten
extrem schwierig zu sagen,
in den USA moderieren wir nicht und machen kein Fact-Checking und was weiß ich,
in Europa muss es jetzt gemacht werden oder so. Ich glaube, als Europäer würden
wir alle sagen, wir wollen, dass das passiert.
Wir wollen auch von unseren Parteien, dass sie auf eine Umsetzung drängen oder
dass man das eben, mir wäre es wichtig, also ich würde es gerne wissen,
wenn irgendeine Partei sagt, wir wollen es nicht mehr, das soll abgeschafft
werden, aber das ist nicht so.
Es wird unterschiedlich stark darauf betont, dass das umgesetzt wird und dass
man eben jetzt hier da Maßnahmen machen soll.
Aber wie gesagt, die Probleme, die sich ergeben, die werden wir jetzt erst dann
dieses Jahr sehen und das wird nach einer Bundestagswahl sein.
Das werden wir wahrscheinlich auch eher auf europäischer Ebene klären müssen.
Und Alina hat ja eigentlich schon gesagt, die Einzelnen, die sich wirklich noch
inhaltlich signifikant unterscheiden, wären die Linken, die also sehr stärker auf diesem, genau.
Also, aber die, naja ...
Die CDU oder die Union äußert sich an einigen Stellen schon eben auch explizit
regulierungskritisch, also nicht nur beim Thema Datenschutz,
sondern fordert auch nochmal mehr Freiräume für KI und so.
Also da kann man natürlich sagen, ja, das ist eigentlich alles schon beschlossen,
aber da gibt es auch irgendwie so einen Unterton von, nein, nein,
wir wollen da nichts übererfüllen, wir setzen wirklich nur das um,
wo wir nicht anders können.
Und das haben sie auch explizit geschrieben, ne?
Genau, also das ist halt zum Beispiel bei den Grünen ein bisschen anders auch nochmal.
Also die sagen schon auch noch, dass sie die großen Digitalkonzerne überhaupt
mal problematisch finden und da Regulierung halt sinnvoll finden.
Das ist bei der Union ein komplett anderes Narrativ. Das finde ich schon noch wichtig.
Da muss man noch eine nicht erwähnte europäische Regelung hinzunehmen,
das passt nämlich hier dazu, nämlich der AI Act, also die KI-Verordnung,
die ist ja jetzt auch geltendes Recht und offenbar, also da sind ja auch noch
ein paar Sachen unklar, wie sie umgesetzt werden, auch von der Aufsicht und so,
da ist offenbar bei der CDU der einzig große Unterschied, die einfach sagen, so wenig wie möglich.
Also das wird dann so in diese Hemd die Innovationen geschoben.
Bei der FDP nicht,
Das überrascht mich gerade ein bisschen, weil da hätte ich auch gedacht,
dass die ja regulierungsfeindlich sind.
Ich wollte eine kritischere Regulierung von AI, also von KI-Systemen.
Das ist generell halt eine Sache, dass, also man muss so ein bisschen diese Frage stellen,
wenn ich sage, ich möchte nicht über das hinweggehen, was in Europa passiert
ist, wie die CDU das macht, oder wenn ich sage, ich brauche eine bessere Umsetzung,
ich brauche eine maßvolle Regulierung hier, meine ich damit eigentlich was anderes?
Also ich meine, es ist vielleicht nur ein unterschiedliches Wording,
aber im Endeffekt kommt genau das gleiche bei raus.
Und da muss ich auch ganz klar sagen, da werden wir eh nicht viel Gestaltungsspielraum haben.
Also man kann da zwar in einigen Punkten theoretisch drüber hinausgehen,
das will man, wenn man die Wirtschaft fördern will, wird man das nicht machen.
Und man sieht ja überall, das ganze Wahlprogramm, AI-Einsatz hier,
AI-Einsatz dort, in der Verwaltung dort und so weiter und so fort.
Da würde man sich ja selbst im Prinzip ein Bein stellen, wenn man dann deutlich
über das hinausgehende, was von der EU kommt, Regulierung fordern würde oder
selber aufbauen wollte.
Ich erwarte da gar nichts, von keiner der Parteien irgendwas,
was über das, was von der EU als Mindestvorgabe da ist, hinweggehen wird.
Das wäre jetzt ein bisschen mein letzter Punkt gewesen, aber durch die Bank
weg die Parteien als eher Chance als Risiko?
Würde ich so sehen, aber ich würde gerne nochmal einmal auf die Metaebene wechseln.
Mir ist aufgefallen, weil wir jetzt so viele europäische Regelungen hatten,
Digital Marketers Act und KI-Verordnung und so.
Und die Schwerpunkte, wie stark man sich irgendwie auf Deutschland fokussiert
oder wie stark man Europa oder sogar international mit reinmacht,
finde ich krass unterschiedlich.
Am stärksten ist es mir auch bei den Grünen, die schreiben sehr viel über Europa.
Auch mit so ein paar Begriffen, wo mir überhaupt nicht klar ist, was die damit meinen.
Also ich nehme mal ein Beispiel, so was, wie sie wollen den europäischen Binnenmarkt
vertiefen und eine vertiefte Digitalunion und so, also sie haben auch manchmal
Sachen, die dann gar nicht, wohl gar nicht, was mit meinen die damit,
aber der Fokus ist teilweise auch krass unterschiedlich.
Von, ich blicke letztlich auf mein Land zu einem umfangreichen europäischen Blick.
Also wer sich zum Beispiel jetzt so sagt, okay, für mich spielt nicht nur eine
Rolle, ja, Digitale Fragen im nationalen Raum, sondern auch im europäischen
und sogar internationalen Raum, der wird am ehesten, finde ich, bei den Grünen.
Fand ich bemerkenswert unterschiedlich.
Wobei das ja eigentlich total realistisch erstmal ist, dass viele dieser Themen
ja einfach auf EU-Ebene behandelt werden.
Wir sind ja gerade noch eigentlich darüber reingekommen, auch über diese Frage
nach den großen Digitalkonzernen.
Also das ja auch sinnvoll ist, dass auf deutscher Ebene, also man kann dann
immer was anstoßen, aber da wirklich mehr erreichen wird man auf EU-Ebene.
Aber da ist Deutschland eben nun mal auch eine wichtige Stimme.
Also deswegen finde ich, ist das total sinnvoll, das von vornherein so zusammen zu denken.
Sorry, wenn ich das da ganz kurz nochmal, bevor wir zur KI gehen,
das nochmal ganz kurz kommentiere, weil ich nämlich schon finde,
dass man bei Digitalregulierung prinzipiell mehr machen könnte.
Also diese Auslassung, ja.
Also da ist einfach so zu sagen, ja wir haben jetzt ja den DSA und gleichzeitig
passieren gerade Dinge mit Musk und so weiter,
auf die irgendwie keiner so richtig vorbereitet war, bei denen halt irgendwie
viele sagen so, ja also legal ist das, aber eigentlich ganz fürchterlich,
also wie gehen wir damit um?
Also ich glaube da überhaupt nochmal sich die Risiken von Digitalisierung vor
Augen zu führen, beziehungsweise inwiefern das gestaltet werden sollte,
das ist, ja da würde ich also sagen, eindeutig bei der Linken der Fall,
aber halt auch in Ansätzen bei den Grünen, aber bei den anderen halt komplett,
ja Digitalisierung ist doch vor allem gut.
In USA sehr stark kompisieren, die breiten sich offenbar auf die Macht über
eine Runde von Frank da vor.
Das ist natürlich erst so nachher richtig in der Debatte. Vielleicht so schriftlich
abbilden konnten wir das nicht. Aber ich teile es bei der Medien,
das hat ein bisschen wenig so.
Ich meine, alle jammern über Desinformation und Übereinfluschungsnetzwerke.
Und dann hatten wir ja noch dieses Urteil zu Rumänien, die wollen unsere Wahl.
Und das teilt nicht so wirklich. Genau.
Also das war eigentlich schon vorher, bevor jetzt irgendwie die so Maske und Sacker
Millionen spenden und zu Kreuze kriechen, das ist echt schlimm.
Also so ein bisschen erteilt, aber ich würde sagen, im Wahlkampf wird es wieder
keine große Rolle spielen, außer wenn es vielleicht so weitergeht und Musk jetzt
irgendwie jede drei Tage irgendwas zur AfD und zu Olaf Scholz sagt, dann vielleicht.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das so weitergehen würde. Keine Ahnung.
Ihr habt ja mitgekriegt, irgendwie Olaf Scholz sagt jetzt irgendwie don't feed
the troll, womit er sich ja explizit zu Musk äußert. Also damit geht der wieder los, medial.
Ich bin gespannt, wie das wird. Es sind ja nur noch sechs Wochen, die halten wir noch aus.
Mal sehen. Jetzt hatte ich am Anfang angekündigt, dass wir jetzt nochmal jeder Partei einzeln widmen.
Und ich frage mich, ob das auch notwendig ist. Ich kann vielleicht nochmal ganz
kurz abfragen, Aber auch die Antworten auf die Fragen, die ich jetzt stelle,
klangen schon so ein bisschen durch.
Trotzdem nochmal, welche Parteien haben einen digitalen Teil in ihrem Wahlprogramm,
den ihr wirklich als digitales Wahlprogramm bezeichnet würde und wer hat eher so das Auge,
das müssen wir auch noch irgendwo abschreiben, die Hausaufgaben.
Gibt es irgendjemanden, der sich vortut, wo er sagt, das ist doch mal ein ordentliches
Programm, auch wenn man jetzt vielleicht nicht irgendwie,
nicht übereinstimmt, inhaltlich, aber sozusagen im Sinne von,
da hat sich jemand wirklich Gedanken gemacht und ich meine jetzt nicht die Länge,
weil es ist sehr einfach, sehr viel Text zu produzieren, sondern wo sagt ihr,
diese Partei hat tatsächlich ein Wahlprogramm beschrieben,
aus dem ich lese, dass sie sich mit dem Thema auseinandergesetzt haben und nochmal,
ich meine damit nicht, dass sie inhaltlich damit übereinstimmt,
sondern einfach sozusagen die haben, wenn es ein Ein Debattierclub wäre ihre
Hausaufgaben gut gemacht.
Ich hatte vorhin ganz eingangs schon mal erwähnt, dass das digital überall so
reingesickert ist mittlerweile und das zieht sich durch alles durch,
egal über was die reden, ob die über Zusammenhalt in der Gesellschaft,
über was weiß ich, digitale Antragstellungen, alles mögliche.
Digital ist einfach überall da drin, aber nicht mehr so explizit als eigenes
digitales Wahlprogramm.
Das habe ich eigentlich bei der FDP, glaube ich, so ziemlich als einziges,
als echten zusammenhängenden Block von den Forderungen, aber auch nicht wirklich was Neues.
Das sind eigentlich die ganzen alten Forderungen, die sie da drin hatten.
Die haben das so kondensiert nochmal da zusammengezogen.
Bei den anderen ist wirklich Digitalisierung mehr so ein Given durch alles durch jetzt.
Das ist mein Teil zumindest da drauf.
Also ich bin da ehrlich gesagt gar nicht so entschieden, ob ich das so problematisch
finde, weil das aus meiner Sicht schon noch ein Stück weit hier abbildet,
dass Digitalisierung, wenn man davon so sprechen kann,
halt etwas ist, was Dynamiken in allen möglichen Gesellschaftsbereichen nach sich zieht.
Und also deswegen, ja, dass es bestimmte Themen gibt, bei denen wir uns mehr
Prominenz wünschen, liegt glaube ich auch daran, dass wir da halt so tief drinstecken.
Aber wenn man sich fragt, wie berührt das Menschen auf der Straße,
wie man so schön sagt, also was für ein Unterschied macht das in dem Leben von
Menschen, dann ist es doch auch eher ein Querschnittsthema.
Und da finde ich vielleicht nochmal diese Frage nach Verwaltungs,
Digitalisierung, digitaler Staat, da habe ich so den Eindruck,
wird unterschiedlich viel drüber geredet.
Ja, aber dann haben wir eine fiese Auslassung jetzt wieder, also thematisch.
Wenn du jetzt sagst, okay, was den Alltag von Menschen irgendwie betrifft,
dann müssen wir glaube ich zumindest nochmal kurz ansprechen,
was sagen die eigentlich zu Digitalisierung in der Bildung und in den Schulen und so.
Also da sind ein paar Unterschiede und das glaube ich wird viele Menschen im
Alltag ziemlich, Kinder und Enkel und so, interessiert.
Also, finde ich, da wird es oft konkreter. Aber ich will mal ein Beispiel nennen,
weil mir das so aufgefallen ist.
Also, natürlich die Parteien, die jetzt regiert haben, die betonen natürlich
so ein bisschen, gerade im Bereich der Digitalisierung, der Bildung,
dass sie schon einige geschafft haben.
Das ist mir generell so aufgefallen. Die Ampelparteien haben natürlich jetzt
in ihr Zukunftsprogramm auch immer nochmal drinstehen, was sie alles schon toll geschafft haben.
Na gut, aber wir wollen klar machen, dass das für uns ein Thema ist,
dass die Schulen digitalisiert gehören und dass wir Leute unterstützen wollen,
die vielleicht nicht so viel Kohle haben.
Das haben halt einige explizit drin. Und das ist mir persönlich zum Beispiel,
glaube ich, für viele Leute im Alltag wichtig.
Also die Grünen haben zum Beispiel explizit drin, sie wollen so ein Zukunftsinvestitionsprogramm
Bildung, das nennt sich auch so.
Sie wollen mit den Ländern mehr arbeiten, in der Bildungspolitik,
das ist ja viel Länderarbeit und so weiter.
Die Linken haben es drin, also die SPD erwähnt es.
Also ich finde nur den Bereich und so richtig so digital ausgestattete Klassenräume,
also da haben sie mehr, da wird es ein bisschen konkreter, jetzt auch nicht
übermäßig und wir wissen ja auch, dass der Bund nicht so viel da regeln darf,
das ist ja schließlich eine Bundestagswahl. Ich wollte gerade sagen,
Es ist wohlfeil, da Dinge zu versprechen.
Ja, aber zumindest, also so schwerpunktmäßig würde ich jetzt schon so sehen,
während ich mal ein Beispiel nenne, womit man die Schuhe ausgezogen hat,
auch weil ich offengestanden vom BSW noch nie im Wahlprogramm gelesen habe,
die haben wir noch relativ kurz, das ist eine Stichwortsammlung,
da geht es ja im Wesentlichen um Soziales, um Migrationspolitik und um Ukraine,
andere Themen haben die ja kaum, aber sie haben einen Absatz drin, völlig aus der Kalten,
ich lese euch das mal kurz vor.
Sie wollen ein Social-Media-Gesetz nach australischem Vorbild.
Um Gottes Willen. Genau.
Und das ist ja, weil ihr das mitbekommen habt, der Plan in Australien ist ja
für soziale Medien ein Verbot für alle unter 16 Jahren.
Wobei das natürlich nicht Messenger und auch nicht YouTube, sondern nur große
Plattformen wie TikTok oder Instagram oder Twitter.
Die beziehen sich drauf, auch Twitter, so sagen, fällt da vielleicht nicht zwangsweise.
Doch, Twitter fällt runter.
Pass auf, sie beziehen sich drauf, dass die Social Media Plattformen gesperrt
werden sollen, die nicht öffentlich wahrnehmbar sind.
Das heißt, alles was Twitter machen würde, ist, sie würden wieder ausschalten,
dass man einen Account braucht, um die Sachen zu lesen.
Dann würden sie schon wieder nicht über diese Regelung fallen.
Und Funfact in der Sideline,
das wird mit Kinderschutz verargumentiert, was tatsächlich politisch in Australien passiert ist,
dass sie eine Auseinandersetzung hatte mit dem Murdoch-Imperium und das Murdoch-Imperium
hat daraufhin eine Kinderschutzkampagne installiert, die sagt,
wir müssen doch schützen und das Ziel ist sozusagen den Plattformen Reichweite zu nehmen,
weil man denkt, dann kommen die Leute wieder immer auf die klassischen Medienseite.
Also als politische Partei in Deutschland zu schreiben, wir wollen was nach
dem Vorbild von dem, was in Australien passiert ist, das ist für mich schon
fast so ein Single-Point-offen unwählbar.
Ich war auch überrascht, weil das das Einzige ist, wo Sie mal so Bildungs- oder
Kinder- oder Jugendlichen-Themen erwähnen.
Sie haben noch einen Satz danach.
Sie verbinden das mit der Förderung von Sportvereinen, die sollen lieber rausgehen.
Und dann haben sie den Satz, statt krankmachender Social-Media-Algorithmen brauchen
Kinder mehr Bewegung, Spaß und Freunde. Auch außerhalb der Schule.
Sonst kommt nichts in diesem Kurzprogramm dazu. Und das haben sie dann drin. Ich dachte so, what?
Und das ist total fantastisch, weil das Social-Media-Algorithmen sozusagen nicht
gut für uns und die Gesellschaft sind, Da kann man total trefflich drüber sprechen.
Ja, aber wir verbieten es.
Aber das damit zu verknüpfen, das war, naja, okay.
Und dann steht aber auch nicht wirklich drin, also wenn du das liest als unbedarfter
Leser und gar nicht weißt, weil die in Australien da gerade debattieren,
wir müssen es dann ja eigentlich ein bisschen explizieren. Das ist ja so ein
bisschen verklausuliert.
Also ich musste die Passage zweimal lesen, für mich ist damit das BSW ja auch
nicht mehr wählbar, falls man das vorher überhaupt erwogen haben könnte.
Aber auch da, Konstanz, es klang jetzt bei dir so ein bisschen als seien da
viele ähnlich positioniert, also vielleicht ist das innerhalb der Ampel,
aber darüber hinaus ist das Spektrum schon groß.
Bei der CDU hatten wir halt diese, beispielsweise die Schüler-ID,
wohingegen die Linke dann so ein Satz hat wie, KI darf nicht für Bewertung oder
die Vorhersage von Lernerfolgen eingesetzt werden.
Das sind glaube ich schon unterschiedliche Visionen, die dahinter stehen.
Ja, richtig. Das sollte man betonen, ich habe jetzt ein bisschen auf die Ampel
oder die Ex-Ampel abgestellte, stimmt, ja.
So, nochmal zum Schluss sozusagen ein kleiner Rundgang durch die Parteien.
Oder müssen wir noch einen Parteienrundgang machen oder haben wir eigentlich alles?
Ich würde eine Sache noch erwähnen, die mir aufgefallen ist,
die niemand anders hatte. Was digital den betrifft, darf ich?
Na bitte?
Mir ist aufgefahren, im grünen Programm steht explizit, dass die Barrierefreiheit
konsequent umgesetzt werden soll,
dass sie öffentlich zugängliche Angebote und Dienstleistungen sozusagen hinsichtlich
der Barrierefreiheit stärken wollen und allerdings auch eine Überforderungsklausel
für kleine Unternehmen haben und ein digitales Barrierefreiheitstool anbieten
wollen zur Unterstützung. Das fand ich sehr konkret.
Also war auch so ein bisschen wenig eingebettet, aber es ist eine sehr konkrete
Forderung, die ja letztlich auch nur umsetzt, was ja eigentlich schon in den
Gesetzen steht und aber eine Hilfe ist.
Also mit einem, weiß nicht, ist mir jetzt aufgefallen, ist euch das aufgefallen?
Mir ist es aufgefallen, aber das fiel bei mir unter die Kategorie,
wie das so ein Ding war, schon Gesetz ist.
Also wo wir einfach noch in der Übergangsfrist sind. Nein, ist,
weil wir in der Übergangsfrist sind.
Wenn das nicht zurückgerollt wird, muss es umgesetzt werden,
muss jede Webseite diese Einbindung haben und so weiter und so fort.
Aber es wären auch Apps und so, eine Dienstleistung haben sie.
Ja, aber die Integration musst du ja sowieso leisten. Also das Unternehmen musste
die Integration leisten, dass eben der Hilfsdienst desjenigen,
der das in Anspruch nehmen muss,
eingebunden wird bei dir, unabhängig davon, was dieser Dienst erstmal ist.
Das ist eine super komplizierte Geschichte momentan.
Aber das kann man vielleicht noch verbessern und kann das anders machen.
Ich finde es schön, dass sie es erwähnen.
Sie erwähnt es halt.
Genau, ich finde es schön, dass sie es erwähnen. Aber für mich sind immer diese
Erwähnungen von etwas, was schon umgesetzt ist eigentlich oder was sich in der
Umsetzung befindet, ist immer extrem schwierig.
Und eine Pflicht ist, ja. Genau, die eh schon verpflichten.
Ja, okay, da habe ich den Punkt.
Ich bin da gerade so unentschieden, weil einerseits ist natürlich,
gibt es gerade in der politischen Kommunikation immer die Gefahr zu sagen,
guckt mal her, was wir Tolles fordern, aber es gibt es eigentlich schon.
Und andererseits finde ich es aber auch, was ich vorhin noch gesagt habe,
finde ich es auch sozusagen nicht unwichtig zu sagen, also es gibt hier diese
Dinge, die gibt es schon und zu denen bekennen wir uns auch.
Ich bin aber unentschieden, wie Roman es, also ich muss jetzt gerade an dieses
Beispiel aktuell denken, es gibt gerade Banken, die sagen so,
liebe Kunden, zu eurem Vorteil, was wir jetzt machen, ist Echtzeitüberweisung,
kostenlos, das machen wir für euch.
Das ist halt gesetzlich vorgeschrieben, dass das jetzt so sein muss.
Und das gibt es natürlich beim Wahlversprechen genauso. Deswegen bin ich so
ganz unsicher, aber ich fände zumindest sozusagen einen erwähnenswerten sehenswerten
Unterschied, ob das Thema Barrierefreiheit in einem Wahlprogramm überhaupt vorkommt
oder nicht, das fand ich jetzt schon.
Aber das ist generell, das grüne Wahlprogramm tut generell sehr viele Sachen, die,
jetzt umgesetzt wurden oder die sie quasi erreicht haben auch und so weiter,
eine Fortschreibung davon, eine Weiterführung davon, das ist aber auch nochmal
zu erwähnen im Prinzip, das ist generell auch mit der europäischen Einbettung,
die wir vorhin schon angesprochen haben, das ist eigentlich so das,
generelle, die CDU ist eher so bei dem bei dem, was wollen sie anders machen,
was wollen sie wieder abschaffen, so nach der Bette.
Wenn vieles davon eigentlich gar keine Abschaffung ist,
Wenn man es mal genau nimmt, weil es gar kein Konzept dafür gibt.
Man schreibt einfach nur, wir wollen das wieder abschaffen, irgendwo zwischendrin,
weil das sind immer so die Highlights, die man nicht mag bei dem anderen,
aber eigentlich, wenn man alles außenrum liest, wollen wir genau das gleiche
dann doch wieder irgendwie umsetzen.
Das fand ich sehr, sehr schwierig in dieser ganzen Geschichte,
was auch, also wenn wir jetzt beim Allgemeinen sind von den Parteien,
ist es mir auch oft gefallen, das ist natürlich jetzt aus Wirtschaftsdienst
sehr unternehmerfreundlich, also da ist so eine wirklich typische Merz-Handschrift
irgendwo drin, also jetzt muss man mal von dem Hintergrund her sagen, weil...
Vieles sind auch gute Ideen, muss ich auch mal sagen.
Also Sachen, wo wir echt Lücken haben, Startup-Förderung, Wagniskapital-Themen
und so weiter, die wir nehmen.
Also die haben wirklich viele gute Sachen da drin, die in Deutschland nie funktioniert
haben und die jetzt auch erstmal nicht gegen die, also die ich jetzt auch nicht
negativ empfinden würde, auch soziale sowas nicht als negativ empfinden würde.
Weil es ist schön, dass es mal einer aufgeschrieben hat und zum Wahlprogramm gemacht hat.
Das ist tatsächlich ein positiver Aspekt da drin. Also das muss man glaube ich auch mal erwähnen.
Ansonsten ist es halt generell so, wer hat sich auf soziale Themen mehr bezogen?
Das ist halt ganz klar auch mehr so bei SPD und sowas, ja nicht überraschend.
Aber das grüne Wahlprogramm ist auch sehr stark unternehmensorientiert oder
überhaupt wirtschaftsorientiert.
Also Wirtschaft ist ganz klar bei CDU, CSU und bei den Grünen das zentrale Thema.
Und Digitales wird dann eben halt oft für diese Zwecke wiederum genutzt.
Wir sind jetzt ja ein bisschen über das Thema KI geskippt und da fand ich,
hat sich das auch nochmal ganz interessant so aufgezeigt,
dass die CDU oder die Union mal wieder halt sagt, sie hätte gerne KI und Cloud
für die Zitat Reindustrialisierung.
Und wegen wir dann auf der anderen Seite vom Spektrum halt die Linke haben,
die sagen, es geht darum, Technologien
zu bewerten im Hinblick auf ihren Nutzen für die Gesellschaft.
Interessant, dass man sowas halt sagen muss und damit dann auch plötzlich so
alleine steht. Und da fand ich zum Beispiel bei der SPD ist teilweise so ein
bisschen erschreckend, dass sie schon auch viel so setzen auf so etwas wie KI
als allgemeines Heilsversprechen.
So, wir wissen nicht so richtig, wie wir das angehen, also werfen wir KI drauf.
So als, ja, oder auch Quantentechnologie kommt da ein paar mal drin vor, wo man, okay,
ja, also da finde ich, ist so ein, sagen wir mal, kritischer oder aufgeklärter
Umgang mit digitalen Technologien lässt an vielen Stellen noch zu wünschen übrig,
sodass, also ja, ich da auch mal wieder ein bisschen hin und her gerissen bin,
so, hätte ich mir gewünscht, dass sie da mehr zu schreiben, naja.
Wenn sie sich mehr dazu informiert hätten, super. Aber auf dieser Ebene,
auf der das da aktuell passiert, gestaltet es lieber hinterher vernünftig aus,
wenn ihr entschieden habt, was ihr wollt,
statt da irgendwie so steile Thesen in den Raum zu stellen, die halt sehr schwer zu halten sind.
Ah, ein Punkt noch. Sorry, mein absoluter Pizarrometer.
Ja, wow.
Die FDP bringt das Thema Bitcoin wieder ganz nach oben und möchte Krypto-ETFs
und fordert Bitcoin als, wie war das,
als anerkannte Währungsreserve bei der Europäischen Zentralbank. Wow.
Ja, dann könnte die vielleicht die Europäische Zentralbank wieder ein paar Atomkraftwerke
aufmachen, um zu meinen.
Soll die Fett doch jetzt auch machen im Nachtraum. Aber das ist übrigens auch ein generales Ding.
Also ich meine, es wird überall KI geschrieben, aber irgendwie ein klares Energiekonzept,
wie man die mit Energie versorgen könnte oder wie man überhaupt das hinkriegt.
Das ist auch so ein bisschen, es kommt zwar vor überall so ein bisschen,
alle wollen sie Energie günstiger machen, aber so richtig klar.
Wie machen wir das jetzt eigentlich oder wie wollen wir das eigentlich angehen?
Da fehlt mir so ein bisschen die Vision, wie das weitergehen soll.
Das ist mir so ein weiter so bei einigen und oh, wir prüfen mal wieder mal,
ob wir nicht doch noch nuklear wieder machen können bei der CDU oder so.
Aber immerhin ist es nur noch ein, wir prüfen mal.
Alle Energieversorger haben ja gesagt, nein.
Das passiert sowieso nicht. Das ist viel zu teuer. Also ganz realistisch.
Auch pro Kilowattstunde. Das ist einfach viel zu teuer, wenn man sich die Preise
von denen, was jetzt in Frankreich online gekommen ist oder was dann in UK gebaut
wird oder sonst. Sonst wenn ich das runterbreche auf Preis pro Kilowattstunde,
ist das einfach utopisch.
Aber für diese ganzen KIs, die überall stehen, da muss man ja auch erstmal Rechenleistung,
Datacenter und so weiter bereitstellen und irgendwie muss ich die mit Strom
versorgen und das wird nochmal eine spannende Aufgabe.
Da fehlt jegliche Antwort drauf. Wir schreiben es ja überall KI rein,
so Passwort ist ja nett, aber dass man das eben mit einem tragfähigen Versorgungskonzept
versehen muss, weil es halt eine Konkurrenz ist.
Da wird in den USA offener darüber gesprochen, dass das eine Konkurrenz ist.
Das haben wir hier jetzt in unserem Wahlkampf zumindest nicht reingekommen.
Das stimmt, auch bei Bitcoin nicht. Alina hat ja jetzt auch kurz die FDP-Forderung
für Bizarro-Meter erwähnt. Das denkst du auch echt.
Ich würde gerne, also am Ende dieser Sendung stellt sich für mich ein wenig
überraschend vielleicht, aber man kann es ja immer mal wieder versuchen heraus,
Wahlprogramme sind vor allen Dingen das, Wahlprogramme.
Also sagen, für eine beliebige Definition von belastbar sind sie belastbar,
aber ich weiß nicht so genau, wo die liegt.
Und würde dann eine Abschlusszuspitzungsrunde mit euch machen wollen.
Und zwar für die nächste Legislaturperiode könnt ihr euch ein für euch wichtiges
Digitales Thema aussuchen und sagt mir dann,
welche Partei oder vielleicht sogar Parteien seht ihr sozusagen aufgrund des
Wahlprogramms oder meinetwegen auch aufgrund eurer Erfahrung in der Lage da
sozusagen was zu reißen.
Also für die nächste Legislaturperiode wichtiges digitalpolitisches Thema,
welche Partei wird es erfüllen?
Seid ihr bereit? Nein.
Ist das eine Aussage über die
Qualität der Wahlprogramme oder die Digitalpolitik in Gesamtdeutschland?
Nee, es ist mehr so eine Aussage dazu, dass egal was hinterher rauskommt,
ich will in Zusammenarbeit muss. Nein, also,
da bin ich natürlich in der schwierigen Position, weil natürlich auch keine
einheitliche Okay, dann machen wir es bei dir so.
Wichtiges digitalpolitisches Thema für die nächste Legislaturperiode.
Das wichtigste Thema digitalpolitisch für die nächste Legislaturperiode.
Also, wenn ich es gesamtgesellschaftlich sehe, es ist tatsächlich für mich so
ein bisschen sowas wie Plattformkontrolle,
Medienkontrolle, halte ich für extrem wichtig, dass wir das gesellschaftlich
in den Griff kriegen und ich hoffe, dass wir da auch ein vernünftiges Konzept
für bekommen, egal wer jetzt rankommt.
Also, infrastrukturetätisch müsste ich natürlich sagen, Data Center und Energie
und überhaupt, aber ich also rein gesellschaftlich und das ist,
glaube ich, hier der entscheidende Punkt.
Weil Konz eh das letzte Wort haben wird, Aline. Wichtige digitalpolitische Aufgabe,
die du siehst und wer kann sie deiner Meinung nach vielleicht erfüllen?
Naja, also ich beschäftige mich auch eben viel mit dem Thema Marktmacht und der Digitalkonzerne,
die ja durch KI einfach nochmal richtig auf die Spitze getrieben wird und wo
ich dann halt mit großem Unbehagen so etwas sehe wie bei der Union und ja bei
der Linken, bei den Grünen so zarte,
also bei den Grünen zarte Ansätze, bei den Linken ein bisschen klarer formulierte
Möglichkeiten sehe oder einen Willen sehe dagegen vorzugehen. gehen.
Ja, ich glaube, auch wenn es dafür auch Europa braucht, ist das,
glaube ich, ein Thema, was man in Deutschland prinzipiell gut setzen sollte
und weiter treiben sollte, statt es zurückzudrehen.
Zweiter Teil der Antwort. Welche Partei siehst du am nächsten in der Lage, da was zu reißen?
Naja, also ich meine, die Linke, der fehlt im Moment halt die politische Unterstützung.
Ich meine, das ist schwierig. Also ich glaube sozusagen, soll ich taktisch wählen
oder soll ich wählen, was sozusagen am ehesten meiner Meinung entspricht,
ist eine Diskussion, die wir heute hier nicht führen können.
Ach damn, ich dachte, wir hatten noch eine Stunde.
Nein, und deswegen sozusagen habe ich das falsch formuliert,
wenn ich sage reißen können, weil das reißen können tatsächlich pragmatisch,
realpolitisch dann diese Frage hat, aber die Frage eher inhaltlich.
Also wie gesagt, zarte Ansätze bei den Grünen,
eine deutliche Überzeugung klingt bei den Linken raus, die das überhaupt als
Problem klar formulieren und verschiedene Ansätze diskutieren,
wie man dagegen sinnvoll vorgehen kann, ja.
Konz?
Also ich fühle mich ja auch ein bisschen schwer mit den, ich glaube,
also die wichtigen Themen zu identifizieren, so an denen ich so festmachen würde.
Für mich wäre denke ich schon auch Massenüberwachung, also wie stellen sich
die Parteien dazu, aber muss ich da ehrlicherweise sagen, dass natürlich bei
manchen der Parteien, die wir heute besprochen haben, das so kurz ist,
weil die ja noch kein vollständiges Wahlprogramm haben, was das fast keine Erwähnung findet.
Insofern würde das vielleicht, wenn Ende Januar komplette Wahlprogramme dazukommen,
vielleicht nochmal ausreferenziert, weiß ich nicht.
Also ich könnte, glaube ich, mit Sicherheit sagen, dass ich den Massenüberwachungsansatz
der Union absolut verfehlt und rückwärtsgewandt finde in so einer digitalen Welt. Aber ich
Neben KI oder Plattformen, was ich auch wichtige Themen finde oder auch IT-Sicherheit,
was nicht stattfindet, glaube ich, dass diese Wahl für mich natürlich nicht
unbedingt an digitalen Themen entschieden wird.
Deswegen tue ich mich natürlich schwer, weil die Aussagen, die jetzt so teilweise
von den Kandidaten getroffen werden, die finde ich so jenseits,
dass ich von den Kandidaten manche einfach nicht wählen könnte,
selbst wenn sie coole Ideen hätten in Digitalien.
Ich tue mich da so ein bisschen schwer mit Dann lass
Mich so sagen, die Frage für dich umformulieren Welche Partei hält sie für wählbar
und dann zusätzlich noch der Aufgabe gewachsenen Überwachungsstaat zu verhindern
Also ich denke von den Ampelparteien fällt für mich durch die Bejahung von Massenüberwachung
die Sozialdemokratie aus Ich finde das einen Paradigmenwechsel den ich abstoßend finde aber
da würde ich wahrscheinlich am ehesten auf Linke, Grüne und Liberale gehen,
aber die Machtoptionen sind natürlich sehr unterschiedlich. Ansonsten.
Also interessant, du hältst die Liberalen für wählbar.
Ich glaube halt einfach nicht, dass sie in den Bundestag kommen und ich finde natürlich auch so eine,
also klar, ich blicke natürlich auch zurück auf das Aus der Ampel und frage
mich, ob ich so eine Leute, die ja auch mit einem Honecker-Ergebnis an Christian
Dündner festhalten wollen, nochmal wählen würde, selbst wenn sie gegen Massenüberwachung
sind. Das ist ja, na watten.
Ich habe auch mal den Sozialliberalenflügel der Liberalen gemocht.
Aber jetzt kommen wir an eine ganz andere Diskussion, die wir jetzt ja hier nicht führen wollen.
Wir wollen vor allen Dingen eins tun, was ich am Ende sagen möchte. Geht da hin.
Wer sich weigert, sein Kreuz zu machen, macht es an der falschen Stelle. Geht da hin. Wählt.
Wir haben die Landtagswahl, da geht uns hier sehen, die sind gruselig.
Ich möchte jeden auffordern, Geht dahin, wählt meine Message.
Musst du nicht teilen, Markus, ihr seht ja aber nicht die Gesichter hier.
Und redet mit Menschen um euch drumherum, also macht diese Themen auch,
also ich bin auch plus eins für,
geht es so sehr um Digitales, also ich glaube Grundrechte und solche Themen
sind manchmal viel wichtiger.
Ja, weil das ist, glaube ich, eigentlich der Punkt. Ich glaube,
hier zeigt sich ein anderes Grundrechtsverständnis und das siehst du in anderen
Themen, nicht nur im Digitalen, ganz doll deutlich.
Deswegen wären für mich eigentlich manche Parteien nicht wählbar.
Und da brauchst du nicht mal die digitalen Themen nehmen, das sind ja auch nur
Ausformungen von Grundrechten.
Insofern, ja, da bin ich so bei dir. Ah, Mann, Alina, hast du wieder das tolle Schlusswort.
Genau, der Erdrutsch in die andere Richtung muss weg.
Um das nochmal ganz deutlich zu sagen, diese Sendung soll keine Wahlempfehlung
für euch sein, sondern diese Sendung soll einerseits Konstanze Kurz die Gelegenheit
geben, mich immer wieder zu unterbrechen,
so wie es im Bundestag Politiker vielleicht auch habe zu machen,
aber andererseits soll ich euch die Möglichkeit geben, diesen einen Aspekt,
nämlich den digitalen im Wahlprogramm nicht selber arbeiten zu müssen,
sondern vielleicht sozusagen einen kleinen Überblick zu bekommen.
Aline Blankertz, Klaus Landefeld, Konstanze Kurz, vielen lieben Dank,
dass ihr da wart und hier wart und egal, egal wer in der nächsten Wahlperiode
an die Macht kommt, es gilt natürlich weiterhin, lasst euch nicht überwachen
und verschlüsselt immer schön eure Backups. Tschüss.
Tschüss.